EMERGE RESPONSE WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE'S SOCIALDISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE STATE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING TODAY'S
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PHYSICALLY
PRESENT AND SOME PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY WE HAVE AT LEAST
TWO MEMBERS OF PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY SENATOR LINDA GONZALES
AND CINNAMON MAKE THE MOMENT.
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WITH ME
THIS AFTERNOON ARE THE VICE
CHAIR SENATOR PATRICIA BATES AS
WELL AS SENATOR ANDREAS
BORCHERS- AND ALSO WITH US IS
ASSEMBLYWOMAN JACQUELINE- WHEN.
WE WILL HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS WITH US TODAY WHO ARE
ALSO PARTICIPATING REMOTELY I
WILL INTRODUCE THEM BRIEFLY AT
THE OPENING OF EACH OF THE
THREE PANELS FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I'D ALSO
ASK THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RCOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PLACE YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN
YOU'RE DONE. TO ENSURE PUBLIC
ACCESS FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WILL ALSO BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE ARE POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE HE WILL THESE
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IS
AND NOW SIT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN LET ME REPEAT
BOTH. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AGAIN
THE ACCESS CODE EIGHT ONE A-
TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
FROM ALL OF THE PANELISTS ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL THE WITNESSES.
WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT. ON THE TOPICS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE IN WHICH YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING PRIOR TO
GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AS CHAIRMAN
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
WHILE WE DON'T ANTICIPATE. THIS
WILL BE AN ISSUE ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE. MAYBE
REMOVING THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MADE. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS ARE THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LEAD TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING TO THE USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS. OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. AND NOW WILL BEGIN.
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
COBIT NINETEEN IS UPENDED ALL
OF OUR LIVES BUT IT IMPACTS
HAVE BEEN FELT MOST ACUTELY. IN
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY.
APOLOGIES FOR THE BRIEF
INTERRUPTION. AT AN EGG HELLO
MR AGAIN THAT COVERED NINETEEN
HAS UPENDED ALL OF OUR LIVES
BUT IT IMPACTS HAVE BEEN FELT
MORE ACUTELY IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY MANY OF US ARE FOR THE
NUMBERS. PREPARED DAMMIT
CALIFORNIA PLAYED ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION RESTAURANT WORKERS
BY MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AT LEAST
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THESE
WORKERS HAVE BEEN LAID OFF OR
FURLOUGHED. NATIONALLY THE
INDUSTRY COLLECTIVELY LOST TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES LAST YEAR.
RESTAURANTS ARE A CRITICAL
SECTOR OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
IN TWENTY NINETEEN ALONE
RESTAURANT FOOD SERVICE JOBS
TOTAL 11% OF EMPLOYMENT IN THE
STATE EVERY DOLLAR SPENT THE
INDUSTRY CONTRIBUTES ANYWHERE
FROM ONE DOLLAR SEVENTY FIVE TO
TWO DOLLARS TO THE STATE
ECONOMY. RESTAURANTS GENERATE
MORE SALES TAX IN CALIFORNIA
THAN ANY OTHER TYPE OF BUSINESS
IN THE LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS
HAVE ONLY BEEN ALLOWED TO
OPERATE IN STRICTLY LIMITED
WAGE. IN DOING SO THEY HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY INCREASED
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC LOSSES TO
THEIR BUSINESSES THEIR
WORKFORCE AND OUR COMMUNITIES
THE FEDERAL PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM WELL IMPLEMENTED
QUICKLY- AND HASTILY TO CUT
HELP COVER PAYROLL COSTS. AS
WELL AS MENTIONED THE CURRENT
FEDERAL RESTAURANT
REVITALIZATION FUND HAVE BEEN
IMPORTANT LIFELINES FOR THE
INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY WHEN
COMBINED WITH ACTIONS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO PROVIDE RELIEF. WERE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL HERE WITH US
TODAY DESCRIBED TO DESCRIBE
SOME OF THOSE RELIEF MEASURES
IN MORE DETAIL LATER ON IN THE
PROGRAM. AMID THE EARLY CHAOS
OF COVE IN NINETEEN THE
RESTAURANTS THAT MANAGED TO
STAY AFLOAT ADAPTED BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO NOW AFTER MONTHS OF
REDUCING THEIR OPERATIONS TO
DELIVERY TAKE OUT AND LIMITED
OUTDOOR DINING MANY RESTAURANTS
HAVE MOVED INTO A DINING.
ALBEIT WITH CAPACITY LIMITS AS
THE STATE'S KOBE CASE NUMBERS
HAVE STABILIZED VACCINE EFFORTS
OF ROLLED OUT IN MOORE COUNTY
SHOULD BE GOING TO OPEN UP
AGAIN. RESTAURANTS HAVE WORKED
HARD TO REOPEN SAFELY AND
INSTITUTED A HOST OF SAFETY AND
SANITATION MEASURES TO KEEP
CUSTOMERS AND STAFF SAFE TODAY
WILL BE HERE FROM A VARIETY OF
OPERATORS IS TO SHARE HOW
THEY'VE ADAPTED THEIR BUSINESS
MODELS TO RESPOND. IT IS CLEAR
THE RECOVERY WILL TAKE AS MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE GET. BECOME
MORE. RETURNING TO PRE PANDEMIC
DINING. AFTER TODAY'S HEARING
WE HOPE TO HAVE A BETTER SENSE.
OF WHAT THE INDUSTRY WILL LOOK
LIKE IN THE FUTURE WHAT THE
STATE CAN AND SHOULD. DO TO
HELP RESTAURANTS BUILD BACK
BETTER. AND WHAT CUSTOMERS CAN
EXPECT IS A STATE LOOKS TO
REOPEN MORE FULLY ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH. BEFORE I BEGIN BEGIN
WHETHER SPEAKERS I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
SPEAK TO CALL AND NOW. PLEASE
DIAL THIS TOLL FREE NUMBER
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT
ONE SEVEN- AND WITH THAT THE
AND ALSO FOR MY VICE CHAIR
SENATOR BATES THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR SOME OF THE COMMENTS AS
WELL. WELL THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN. I KNEW WHEN I
PRECIADO- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE WITH YOU AND I WANT
TO GIVE YOU A HIGH FIVE I THINK
THE WAY YOU'VE SET UP THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PANELS IS
ABSOLUTELY EXCELLENT- THE
BRIEFING PAPER THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED JOBS I THINK ONE
SENTENCE AND IT SAYS THAT ALL
IT'S IN THE INTRODUCTION FEW
SECTORS. HAVE BEEN BATTERED
MORE BY THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY THAT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING BUT IT NEEDED TO BE SAD
SO THAT OUR CHAIRMAN COULD PUT
TOGETHER A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
ON THESE PANELS WHO HAVE HAD A
LITTLE PIECE OF THE WHOLE THING
OF HAVING TO DO THE OVERSIGHT.
IMPOSED THE RESTRICTIONS AND
DAN ARE RESTAURATEURS WHO'VE
HAD TO BEAR THROUGH- A YEAR AND
A HALF OF SOME VERY VERY
SERIOUS SITUATIONS IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT KEEPING THEIR
BUSINESSES OPEN SO THIS IS A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT DAY AND AN
EXCEPTIONAL DAY AGAIN THINKING
THE CHAIR OFF FOR PROVIDING
THEIR FAN PROBABLY I THINK WE
ARE PUSHING IT A LITTLE EARLIER
US SENATOR NEWMAN ABOUT DOING
IT BUT I THINK ALL THIS HAS
BEEN ON A VERY OPPORTUNE TIME.
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING A LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL AND-
WHAT HOW WE GO FORWARD SO WE
MIGHT AVOID THE PITFALLS IN THE
FUTURE AND HELP FROM THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RAMPED UP VERY
QUICKLY AND I MIGHT SAY. I SEE
IT HAPPENING BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT FILE ON THE WEEKEND
STARTING ON FRIDAY TO GET A
RESERVATION- THAT SOME
RESTAURANTS BECAUSE THEY'RE.
ALREADY BOOKED SO IT SHOWS THAT
THE PUBLIC. HAS BEEN ANXIOUSLY
A ALL OF. THIS LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL IN GETTING THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT INDUSTRY UP
AND RUNNING WHICH PROVIDES US
SO MUCH. IN ADDITION TO THE
REVENUES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENJOY FRIENDS AND FAMILY. IN A
WONDERFUL SETTING SO. WITHOUT
TERM LIMITS SO LET'S GET GOING.
I THANK YOU CELEBRATION I GOT
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF PANEL WHICH MAKE AN
OPENING STATEMENT. I APPRECIATE
THAT SO WHAT WE AS WE GET INTO
THE FIRST PAEL I WANT I WANT
TO INVITE. ALL OF THE- OTHER
TWO PARTICIPANTS AND
ASSEMBLYWOMAN URBAN. GUIDE TO
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS PLEASE
JUST LET ME KNOW. AND LIKE TO
KEEP THIS IS INTERACTIVE. AND
PARTICIPATORY AS POSSIBLE- BUT
NOW LET'S FIRST. TURN TO THE
FIRST PANEL TO PROVIDE A LOOK
BACK AT THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
PANDEMIC IT'S RESTAURANTS OF
ALL KINDS ACROSS THE STATE.
WERE REQUIRED TO INSTITUTE A
NUMBERS OF ALL THE EMERGENCY
MEASURES DIRECTED BY THE STATE.
OUR FIRST PANELIST WILL BE DR
MATT WILLIS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER OF MARIN COUNTY
REMEMBER THE STATEWIDE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. DR WILLIS
RELIES ON HIS EXPERIENCE AS A
PHYSICIAN AND EPIDEMIOLOGIST
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS. TO GUIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGY FOR
MARIN COUNTY. HE'S HERE TODAY
SHARES EXPERIENCES WITH
COMMUNICATING IMPLEMENTING AND
ENFORCING PANDEMIC RELATED
POLICIES. ON THE GROUND WELCOME
DOCTOR WILLIS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THANKS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER MY PERSPECTIVE AS A LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER- IN WHAT
HAS BEEN- YOU KNOW A VERY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT FOR US-
IN OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH WITH
OUR COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF.
REGULATIONS IN AN ENVIRONMENT
OF A NOVEL VIRUS THAT. WE WERE-
AT EVERY STAGE GAINING MORE AND
MORE KNOWLEDGE OF THE BEHAVIOR
THIS VIRUS WHAT STRATEGIES
WOULD BE MOST EFFECTIVE. AND
HAVING TO WORK WITH. WITH
INDUSTRY. TO CONTINUOUSLY
MODIFY AN ADAPTER PRACTICES SO.
I SURE- YOU KNOW YOU YOUR SENSE
THAT THIS IS THE BEST APPROACH
TO. INTERACTIVELY AND BY
DIRECTIONALLY AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE I THINK ONE OF THE MESSAGES
I WANT TO OFFER. RIGHT OFF THE
BAT IS THAT- IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS BETTER THE
NEXT TIME I THINK THE
EXPECTATION THAT THIS BE DONE-
IN DIALOGUE- AND WITH CLEAR AND
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND ANY SECTOR THAT'S
IMPORTANT ACTED. BY PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTICE. NEEDS TO BE
CORE TO OUR STRATEGY. I'M I'M
GOING TO. SOME OF SOME OF THE
WAY WE APPROACH THAT IN MARIN
COUNTY SOME TAKING UP A LOCAL
FOCUS AS LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER BUT THAT'S ALSO MY WAY
OF. OF SUGGESTING WHAT I THINK
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES MIGHT BE- MOVING
FORWARD AND ALSO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES- AND SHORTCOMINGS
THAT WE EXPERIENCED HERE IN
MARIN- AND HOW THAT MIGHT BE.
BUILT INTO SOMETHING YOU COULD
DO BETTER THE NEXT TIME. SO I
WOULD MORGAN WAS AMONG. THOSE
SIX COUNTIES THAT- A DOCTOR THE
VERY FIRST SHELTER IN PLACE
POLICY ON MARCH SIXTEENTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY- THAT WAS IN
RESPONSE TO WHAT AT THAT TIME
WAS EXPONENTIAL GROWTH IN CASES
PRIMARILY EMANATING OUT OF THE-
SOUTHERN BAY AREA. SANTA CLARA-
AND IT WAS IT WAS CLEAR- AS WE
ARE DEVELOPING EVEN JUST
DEVELOPING THOSE THAT SHELTER
IN PLACE POLICY THAT IT IS ONE
THING TO TRY AND ORGANIZE
SOCIETY. AROUND YOU KNOW
PREVENTING. ACCESS TRANSMISSION
IN THE SETTING OF A AN EMERGING
PANDEMIC- AS THEY OCCUR AS
PEOPLE INTERACT ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY. IT IS ANOTHER THING
TO HAVE THE SPECIFIC AWARENESS
OF EVERY INDUSTRY OUT OF EVERY
BUSINESS TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
THEM THE SPECIFICITY OF
GUIDANCE FOR THEIR PARTICULAR
SETTING AND SO WE RECOGNIZE
RIGHT OFF THE BAT THAT THERE
WAS GOING TO NEED TO BE A
SERIES OF CONVERSATIONS THAT
WOULD FOLLOW. THAT INITIAL
SHELTER IN PLACE THAT WOULD
HELP EVERY INDUSTRY IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY- AND SO OUT OF THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS LOOKING
BACK AT AT THE PRESS RELEASE
THAT WAS RELEASED FOR THIS FOR
SHELTER IN PLACE. I WAS
REMINDED THAT WE CAN FRAME IT
AS A THREE WEEK SHELTER IN
PLACE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW PUTTING ON THE BRAKES FOR
THREE WEEKS TO TRY AND- GET A
GET A- HANDLE ON WHAT WAS
EXPONENTIAL GROWTH OF THAT
TIME. YOUR LITTLE DID WE KNOW
THAT MORE THAN A YEAR LATER
WE'RE STILL OPERATING IN THIS
FRAMEWORK THAT FORTUNATELY
WE'RE LOOKING AT. SOME SETTING
ON ON JUNE FIFTEENTH AND I
THINK WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE FOR
REACHING THE BENCHMARK FOR THAT
DAY AS THE END OF THIS OF THE
SHELTER IN PLACE FOR THE END OF
THE BLUEPRINT- SO. IN MARIN. IN
APRIL. SO JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AFTER WE INITIATED THE CENTER
FOR SHELTER PLACE WE
ESTABLISHED A GROUP CALLED
MARIN RECOVERS. WHICH WAS AN
EFFORT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
WORK WITH INDUSTRY LEADERS
ACROSS ALL DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES. IN BURN CALORIES SO
RESTAURANTS. INSTRUCTION BASED
BASED ORGANIZATIONS RETAIL
ETCETERA- AND HAD LEADERS FROM
THOSE INDUSTRIES ACTUALLY MEET
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH ON A WEEKLY
BASIS. TO WORK OUT WHAT WOULD
BE THE BEST PROCESS AS WE
LEARNED ABOUT THE VIRUS. AND AS
WE LEARN WHAT THE IMPACT WAS.
ON THOSE SECTORS TO TRY AND
HAVE. YOU KNOW I GET A BI
DIRECTIONAL AND TRANSPARENT
CONVERSATION- SO I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE- BEST OF
THE BEST PRACTICES. PERHAPS
THIS IS INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT
ALLOWS INDUSTRY. TO WORK WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTLY. AND
INDIRECTLY- THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. GROUNDED IN- WHAT WE
WHAT WE IN RANDOM MATRIX WAS
SET WHICH WAS THE WORLD HEALTH.
ORGANIZATION DEFINITION OF
HEALTH. WHICH IS- A COMPLETE
STATE OF PHYSICAL SOCIAL AND
MENTAL WELL BEING AND NOT
MERELY THE ABSENCE OF DISEASE.
AND SO WE'RE TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
WELL BEING AS BEING INTRINSIC
TO HEALTH IT REALLY OPENS THE
DOOR FOR RECOGNIZING THE
ECONOMIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
WELL BEING ARE ALSO PART OF
HEALTH. AND NOT MERELY
ORGANIZING EVERYTHING AROUND
EXPLICITLY JUST PREVENTING ANY
PREVENTABLE ACTIVE OF
TRANSMISSION OF COVERT NINETEEN
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT WOULD BE REALLY
SIMPLY TO HAVE EVERYONE. BE AT
HOME CONSTANTLY NOT INTERACTING
AT ALL AND WE KNEW THAT THAT
WAS NOT FEASIBLE FROM AN
ECONOMIC OR SOCIAL STANDPOINT-
SO JUST SOME OF THE MECHANICS
OF THAT MARIN RECOVERS GROUP
WEEKLY MEETINGS. INDUSTRY
INDUSTRY ADVISORS IN MARIN
COUNTY THAT INDUSTRY ADVISE
THAT WAS CHOSEN FOR THE
RESTAURANT REQUEST WAS ARMED BY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DIRECTOR
NOW YOU'LL HEAR FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES SHORTLY
IN. ANOTHER PANELIST. THAT WAS
SO IT'S PROBABLY HEALTH. HEALTH
AND THEN AN INDUSTRY LEADER
FROM WITHIN THE RESTAURANT
SECTOR- AND THEY REPRESENTED
THAT SECTOR AS A WHOLE AND
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS- AT ON AN AD HOC
BASIS SOMETIMES AS
RECOMMENDATIONS CHANGED. OR ON
REGULAR BASIS WEEKLY MEETINGS-
WE ALSO HAD MEMBERS OF CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE WERE PART OF THAT
GROUP FUNCTIONS- RIGHT AS
FORTUNATE AS A MEDIUM SIZE
COUNTY SOURCE MONMOUTH COUNTY
TO HAVE THOSE. SOME
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE THE
WORDS THAT ARE IMPACTED BY OUR
POLICIES- CHAMBERS OF ALL THE
CHAMBER. ELEVEN ALONG WITH
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND THE BRANCH MANAGERS
A STATEMENT MANAGERS AS WELL-
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES OF THAT
PROCESS WAS- BEFORE THE STATE
DEVELOPED WHEN WE HAD US A SITE
SPECIFIC PROTECTION PLAN FOR
MARIN COUNTY. WHERE ALL THE
BUSINESSES WERE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH KIND OF A TEMPLATE AND
SAY OKAY THIS IS HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL
DISTANCING THIS IS HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ACCOMPLISH PERSONAL
COVERAGE YOU KNOW ALL THE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF SAFETY-
WE'RE ALSO ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
THEM. IN IN PREVENTING
OUTBREAKS THAT WOULD CLOSE
RESTAURANTS- YOU KNOW WHEN
SPACE FOR US WE HELP THEM-
CONTROL SPREAD WE HELP THEM
ACTUALLY GET WITH THE TESTING
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO PREVENT.
HAVING TO CLOSE THE BUSINESS
THERE'S AN OTBREAK AND THE
STAFF. YEAH WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY YOU ARE
NOT NOT ABLE TO GET. HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF TO KEEP THE
BUSINESS OPEN. SO WE WERE ABLE
TO- PARTNER WITH AND MOVE
MOBILE TESTING OPTIONS AND
OTHERS. OUT TO RESTAURANTS. OR
OR HAVE DAYS WHERE ALL THE
RESTAURANTS WERE ABLE TO SEND
THEIR EMPLOYEES FOR TESTING-
GREW OUT OF THAT NEEDS YOU KNOW
DETERMINED IN THAT BRAIN
RECOVER SCREW- ANOTHER STRENGTH
WAS- NAVIGATING. STATE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO. AS THE
STATE YOU KNOW AFTER. OUR
SHELTER IN PLACE OBVIOUSLY THE
STATE THEN. IMPOSED A SEPARATE
SHELTER IN PLACE OF THE
BLUEPRINT TO THE TEARS OF THE
COLORS- WITH POLICIES OF THE
COMPANY THAT. THAT WAS
SOMETHING WE NEEDED TO ADAPT TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE THESE
THESE ARE NOT EXTERNALLY-
IMPOSED. ADDED RESTRICTIONS AND
REGULATIONS- WE HAD NO CLUE WE
HAD NO. WE HAD NO CONTROL RIGHT
SO- IMPORTANTLY. LOCAL THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MUST
BE OUT IN LINE WITH CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC PUBLIC HEALTH.
REGULATIONS IN THE FRAME BUT WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE LESS
RESTRICTIVE SO. OUR STRATEGY
SHIFTED FROM LOCAL CONTROL. AND
LOCAL DIALOGUE BASED ON OUR OWN
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REALLY
FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN BEST.
FOLLOW STATE REGULATIONS- AND
THAT'S WHERE THAT I THINK IT
WILL ALL END WITH THIS- YES FOR
MY INTRODUCTORY REMARKS JUST
THAT THAT- WHAT WE MIGHT DO
BETTER. ONE OF THE AREAS THAT I
THINK WAS WS THIS YOUR FRANKLY
A STRUGGLE FOR US WAS. IN THE
INTERPRETATION OF EVIDENCE WHEN
THE STATES- REQUIRE THAT
OUTDOOR DINING BE CLOSE- IT
ALSO SHARES- IT WAS IT WAS A
CHALLENGE IN TERMS OF- IT IN
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT IS THE
EVIDENCE OF FROM MARK FROM
WITHIN IRAQ AFTER THE RECOVER
SCOOP. RESTAURANTS ASKING WHAT
IS THE EVIDENCE BASE FOR NOT
ALLOWING OUTDOOR DINING- AND
OBVIOUSLY. AT THAT POINT WE
DIDN'T HAVE A STRONG EVIDENCE
BASE FOR TRANSMISSION THAT
OCCURRED IN OUTDOOR SETTINGS
PARTLY BECAUSE WE JUST DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH. ENOUGH TIME UNDER
OUR BELTS. FOR KILLING AN EVENT
THAT EVIDENCE WOULD HAVE TAKEN
THE FORM OF. KNOWN ACTS OF
TRANSMISSION THAT OCCURRED IN
OUTDOOR RESTAURANTS- OF A
CERTAIN YOU KNOW IT ENDS AT A
CERTAIN RATE UNFORTUNATELY. WE
OUR CONTACT INVESTIGATIONS WERE
NOT ACTUALLY ABLE TO ASCERTAIN
THOSE WITH THAT LEVEL OF
SPECIFICITY SO WE'RE RELYING
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT
STAY WAS RELYING ON. ON
UNDERSTANDING AND KNOWLEDGE OF
WHERE TRANSMISSION MIGHT OCCUR
WHAT THE CHARGE WAS AN ANNEX R.
AND THEN APPLYING THE
PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE TO SAY
WE BELIEVE THAT THE SETTING IS
SUFFICIENTLY. RISKY TO JUSTIFY
A POLICY THAT PREVENTS THIS
FROM HAPPENING EVEN IN THE
ABSENCE OF SPECIFIC KNOWLEDGE
WHEN THAT MIGHT HAVE OCCURRED I
THINK THAT'S AN AREA WHERE. WE
COULD HAVE DONE BETTER- ENVY OF
THE AND THE STATE MIGHT HAVE
DONE BETTER IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATING THE RATIONALE FOR
THAT DECISION THAT THAT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL JUST FRANKLY WAS
WITH ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
HARDER POLICIES AS I BECAME SO
THE APOLOGIST. FOR STATE
POLICIES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL MY
RELATIONSHIP RESTAURANTS.
SOMETHING JUST YOU KNOW TO BE
ABLE TO DEFEND AS A DECISION.
AGAIN PROBABLY. THE
PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE. ALSO
MAKING MAKING SURE THAT IT'S
THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ORGANIZE OUR SOCIETY AROUND AND
THE QUESTION THAT WE ARE. ONLY
ENGAGING IN ESSENTIAL
ACTIVITIES SO YES FOOD IS
ESSENTIAL YOU CAN GET YOU KNOW
AND RESTAURANTS ARE ESSENTIAL
FOR PROVIDING FOOD. BUT YOU CAN
YOU CAN OBTAIN THAT TO TAKE OUT
IT SO THAT AT AN OUTDOOR DINING
EXPERIENCE IS NOT DEEMED
ESSENTIAL- AND THEN- THE MENTAL
IMAGE WE'RE TRYING TO. YOU KNOW
AND THAT THE VISION OF A
HEALTHY COMMUNITY WAS ONE WHERE
PEOPLE BY AND LARGE SHELTERING
AT HOME HUNKERING DOWN. NOT
ENGAGING SOCIALLY NOT OUTDOORS.
I MEAN NOT NOT OUTSIDE OF THEIR
HOMES THAT WAS SORT OF A
NARRATIVE AROUND WHY WE WERE.
CLOSING OUTDOOR DINING THAT I
THINK WAS NOT EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATED- AND I SAID YOU
KNOW A LESSON LEARNED. A LESSON
LEARNED THERE- AND THEN I'LL
JUST SEND TO S. I DO FEEL FOR
THE FUTURE I DO FEEL HOPEFUL
THAT WE ARE NOW IN A PLACE WITH
A VACCINATION RATES THE CASE
COUNTS CONTINUED DECLINE. JUNE
FIFTEENTH. IS THAT APPROPRIATE
HORIZON FOR US- AND WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT- YOU KNOW MANY OF
THESE YOU KNOW THE PROBLEMS
THAT I'VE DESCRIBED A PROBLEMS
OF THE PAST. HOPEFULLY WE'LL
YOU KNOW WE CAN LEARN FROM THEM
FOR THE NEXT TIME- BUT I AM I
AM SEEING THAT THE FUTURE IS
NOT ONE OF TIGHT REGULATIONS IN
THE RESTAURANT SECTOR- IT YOU
KNOW. FOR MY PART BUT IF I WILL
I WILL. OUR POLICY IN MARIN
COUNTY THE COUNTY LEVEL IT'S
GOING TO BE FOLLOWING THE STAGE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE MORE
RESTRICTIVE THAN THE STATE- AND
WE'RE SEEING THAT IT'S LIKELY
TO BE. A SERIES OF A GUIDANCE
IS BASED ON PRINCIPLES OF
SAFETY AND PERSONAL CHOICE. AND
NOT TIGHT REGULATION AND YOU
KNOW IT AND EVERY ASPECT OF. OF
THE PRACTICE OF. APPROACHING
RESTAURANT. THAT'S THAT'S
ANOTHER SIGN OF THE PROGRESS
FOR MAKING. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL ALSO BE SENT ABOARD
HIS HAS TO LEAVE IT HAS A
QUESTION ONE OF THE GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED CENTER. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. I WANT TO HARKEN
BACK- I LIVE IN FRESNO COUNTY.
AND DURING THE DURING THE
PANDEMIC ONE OF THINGS THAT I
WAS KEEN ON GETTING ACCESS TO
WAS. A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE INDUSTRY TRANSMISSION RATES
MEANING- IF WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SOUND POLICY IN EVERY REGION OF
CALIFORNIA SEEM TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
DIFFERENT PROFILE. IT BE
TERRIBLY HELPFUL AT THAT POINT
TIME FOR US TO UNDERSTAND-
WE'RE THE SIGNIFICANT
TRANSMISSIONS WERE COMING FROM
I WOULD LATER FIND OUT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA- OFFICIALS THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE. THEM AT THIS AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL THROUGH THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THEM AT THE STATE
LEVEL SO WE WERE KIND OF
RELYING ON OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PATHOLOGY OF THE VIRUS TO
MAKE PUBLIC POLICY DECISIONS
BOTH STATE. AND CITY LEVELS AND
AT THE AT THE REGIONAL COUNTY
LEVEL SO MY QUESTION TO YOU. IF
YOU COULD. I THINK THE PURPOSE
OF THIS COMMITTEE AT LEAST FROM
MY APPRECIATION OF IT IS WHAT
LESSONS CAN WE LEARN FROM WHAT
WE EXPERIENCED SO THAT WE CAN
INCORPORATE THAT LEARNING INTO
PREPARATIONS ARE FOR THE
FUTURE. AND SO BASED ON THE
COMMENTARY THAT YOU HAD FIVE A
MOMENT AGO. DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
HAVING A CENTRALIZED. PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTIVE WOULD HAVE
BEEN- MORE FORCEFUL AND
RELIABLE- WAY TO ADDRESS THE
PANDEMIC OR DO YOU NOW LOOKING
BACK FIND THAT THE REGIONAL OR
COUNTY BY COUNTY APPROACH WAS
EFFECTIVE. IF THERE WAS IT WAS
A HYBRID IF SOMEONE SENDS THEM
TO THE FRAMEWORK THAT ALLOWED
EACH COUNTY TO BE CLASSIFIED
BASED ON BURDEN. INTO CERTAIN
POLICIES THAT CORRESPONDED THAT
BURDEN- I THINK THAT THAT
STRATEGY WHILE IT TOOK A WHILE
TO MAKE SURE- OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PANDEMIC- WAS AN
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY THIS IS NOT
MY OPINION IS THAT THAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO RECONCILE BOTH THE
NEED FOR. EVIDENCE BASED ON
CENTRALIZED STANDARDIZED
PRACTICE WITH THE WITH THE
HERITAGE IN AT THE DIFFERENCES
AN ACCOUNT IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA. FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HUGE DIFFERENCES IN.
IN EVERY ASPECT CULTURE
POLITICS RACES AS THEY ALL THAT
AS WELL AS TRANSMISSION RATES.
YOU NEED ASYOU NEED AS A
FRAMEWORK THAT HAS THAT
FLEXIBILITY. OF MY CONCERN
ABOUT COMPLETE LOCAL CONTROL
WOULD BE THAT- THAT THERE WOULD
BE A LOT MORE YOU KNOW OTHER
FACTORS OUTSIDE OF SCIENCE THAT
MIGHT DETERMINE WHAT THE LOCAL
POLICIES WOULD BE. IN JUST A
FOLLOW UP ON THAT I THINK ONE
OF THE LESSONS THAT I
PERSONALLY- TAKE IT AWAY FROM
THE PANDEMIC EXPERIENCE. FIRST
OCCURRED AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
WHERE WE- HAD- IS IN THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION A DECENTRALIZED
APPROACH MEANING THAT STATES
WERE ALLOWED TO MAKE DECISIONS
OF THEIR OWN- AND I THINK THAT
CREATED SOME SOME CHALLENGES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT CAME TO.
PROCUREMENT OF RESOURCES WHERE
MUNICIPALITIES COUNTIES AND
REGIONS WERE COMPETING AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER IN SOME FASHION ON
THE MARKET. THEREBY INFLATING
THE PRICE IN MAKING IT LESS
RELIABLE FOR BUILDING OUT A
PLAN SO IN ESSENCE. I THINK
HAVING A NATIONAL STRATEGY
WOULD HAVE BEEN TERRIBLY
HELPFUL. AS WE WENT THROUGH
THIS PROCESS BUT NOT HAVING
THAT. AT THE STATE LEVEL- I
THINK. THE- HAVING THAT HYBRID
APPROACH THE YOU'RE THE YOU'RE
REFERRING TO- IS A LESSON THAT
WE CAN TAKE AWAY AS HAVING
UTILITY- AND I'LL FINISH WITH
THIS IS THE LA COUNTY WHEN
ASKED WHAT THEIR TRANSMISSION
RATES WERE. IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY THEY HAD A REPORT
INDICATED THAT ROUGHLY 3% OF
THE TRANSMISSIONS THAT THEY
COULD ATTRIBUTE TO THE%
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY NO I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT THAT WAS ENTIRELY
ACCURATE- I THINK IT HAS A LOT
TO DO WITH- A SHORTAGE OF
INFORMATION. IN A BUNCH OF
OTHER EXTERNALITIES OR HARD
INVENTORY IN REAL TIME- BUT
MOVING FORWARD WOULD YOUR
RECOMMENDATION BE THAT THERE
BE- METRICS AND- SAFEGUARDS IN
PROCESS IS PUT INTO PLACE. AT A
REGIONAL LEVEL OR EVEN AT A
COUNTY LEVEL. THAT WE HAVE-
TRACING OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
HAD BASICALLY FORSAKEN DURING
THIS LAST PANDEMIC. YES YEAH I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL FOR US TO
AND WE HAVE WE HAVE A LOT MORE
INFORMATION NOW THAN WE DID.
YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS AGO AND
MANY OF THESE POLICIES WERE
BEING DEFINED WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE RISK THAT
OUTDOOR TRANSMISSION IS MUCH
LOWER- THAT WASN'T AS CLEAR-
FOUR- WE ALSO. HAVE A BUILD UP
OUR OUR CONTRACT DISCUSSION
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT WILL GO WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ASCERTAIN.
WHERE TRANSMISSION IS OCCURRING
MORE PRECISELY- ACROSS SECTORS
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE CRITICAL
INFORMATION FOR US FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT. OR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU YOU ARE
CONCERNED WHICH TED TO GET
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR
WILSON AND LET'S. MOVE EXPANDS
WILL HAVE MORE QUESTIONS AFTER
THE PANEL. OUR NEXT PANELIST IS
JUSTIN MALEN. BETER DIRECTOR
THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. SIX TWO DH IS
CONSIDERABLE IMPATIENT WITH THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND
REPRESENTS THE SIXTY TWO LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ENTITIES
THAT ISSUE PERMITS. TO
RESTAURANTS AND CONDUCT OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS. AND. REALLY
WELCOME- MISTER MOLOT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR BACK- WELCOME TO.
ALL THE GUESTS AND THE AND THE
OTHER- TEN DAYS THERE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
PARTICIPATE TODAY I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF SLIDES WHICH I THINK
MAYBE YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW UP SO.
IF THE FACILITATOR WILL PUT UP
MY SLIDES AGAIN JUST. SURE THAT
SCREEN. I HAVE. EVER GONE. SO
JUST GIVE THEM BACKDOCUMENTS
AGAIN AN EXCELLENT. THE HEALTH
CONCERN. I REMEMBER FOLKS ARE
KIND OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REGULATORS. IF NOT RUN PROGRAMS
THAT MOST OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH SIGNED BALL GAME AND THE
RETAIL FOOD SAFETY SECTOR IS
OUR NUMBER ONE PROGRAM BY FAR
THE LARGEST EVER GOT OVER NINE
HUNDRED LOCALS AND THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN PERMITTING AND
INSPECTION OF SOMETHING LIKE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RETAIL FOOD FACILITIES
NOW THAT'S JUST THE RETAIL
THAT'S WHERE THE FOOD
FACILITIES. FROM HOT DOG CART
ALL RIGHT THROUGH TO THE BIG
BOX STORE AS DINING CONTACT.
WITH THE PUBLIC. OUR SYSTEM
DOES DO THE WHOLE SALE. THAT'S
THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
I'M NOT. GONNA HELP DEPARTMENTS
IN PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH
SOMETIMES IS A CHALLENGE IN
ITSELF- SO ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. CENTER OR IF. SINGLES
FINALS BETWEEN FICTION GROUP
CAL CODE THE RETAIL THROUGH
GOOGLE. AND BECAUSE WE IN THE
TRENCHES WITH THE RESTAURANTS-
INSPECTING THEM TWO THREE.
TIMES DDING YEAH I WE HAVE A
CLOSE LOCAL KNOWLEDGE OF THOSE
RESTAURANTS OF THOSE FACILITIES
AND I FIND PHONES THAT CAN ALSO
BE A VERY SIGNIFICANT ASSET IN
THIS SITUATION LIKE LIKE THIS.
I'M QUITE A ON IN THE PROCESS
AND HELP THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. DEVELOP SAFE TO RETURN
GUIDANCE- AND THE ADDRESS WAS
ADOPTED AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
AND I THINK THE POINSETTIA
RAISED BY NUMBER AGAIN ABOUT
GETTING THIS BALANCE. BETWEEN
STATE DIARY. TELL FRANCO HE'S
ENTITLED STANDARDIZED THE
LOCALS ARE PRE EMPTED INSTEAD
GIRL FROM COMING UP WITH
DIFFERENT LOCAL STANDARDS
RETAIL FOOD BUT OTHERS SEE THIS
LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION YOU
COULDN'T HAVE ONE STATE AGENCY
RESPECTING SOVEREIGNTY
DIFFERENT RESTAURANTS. AND ALSO
WORKED FAIRLY EARLY ON WAS THAT
WE WOULD BE INTERESTED PARTIES
ARNOLD BILLS LIKE AB SIXTY ONE
WHICH WAS AN EFFORT TO SORT OF
ACCOMMODATE THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY FROM A- SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE AND ALLOW THEM TO
DO CERTAIN. THINGS I DON'T. THE
BAND ALONG. IN AND SENSE AND I
CAN TRY ON THOSE A LITTLE BIT
SET ON A BIT LATER- NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. I YOU CAN ASK FOR SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND WE DID
ALL OUR MEMBERS I WAS AT THE
RESIDENTIAL TURN AROUND SO WE
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO RESPOND
BUT I THINK I DO A FAVOR HERE
AND IT'S FAIRLY CONSISTENT I
THINK THEY'VE GOT TO ACTION
TALKING TO OUR MEMBERS REDRESS
IS QUITE WELL REFLECTED ON THE
SURVEY RESULTS BUT WHEN YOU ARE
AS WELL IN FACT. IN- THANK THEN
WE CAN DANCE WORKPLACE SAFE
POLICY. AROUND I WAS PERCENT OF
OUR FOLKS FACT THE NUMBERS THAT
CAME IN RECENT TIMES. WELL SO
HAVE A 60% YES WHY AM STAY WILL
COMFORTABLE BECAUSE THEY-
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXPERTS IN
FOOD SAFETY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE LOCAL CONNECTIONS THEY WERE
ABLE TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY TO GET THIS INFORMATION
OUT AND EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE BOTH
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
THOSE CUSTOMERS WHY HE'S
REQUIREMENTS WITH THE HAND
PLACED- I THINK THAT I HAVE A
LOT OF CHRIST. WAS FAIRLY HIGH
IN THE BEGINNING PEOPLE REALIZE
THIS IS A MASSIVE ABSENT TO
ALLIANCE AND LARGELY- WELL
ACCEPTED IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF
IT- THERE WAS INCONSISTENT
SUPPORT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
AND GAMES THAT COMES BACK TO
THE ISSUE OF- BALANCING STATE
AND LOCAL RESPONSE AS SOMETIMES
THE LOCALS FELT THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE SUPPORT FOR THEM
SOMETIMES LOCALS FELT THAT THEY
WANTED. MORE WELL THEY AREN'T
SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO SAY
THAT ONE APPROACH AS I SAID
EARLIER IS BETTER THAN THE
OTHER BUT BY AND LARGE WE HAD
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND TO HELP
EITHER IN EMPLOYMENT THE STATE
POLICIES THE POLICIES THAT THE
HEALTH OFFICERS UNDER THAT SORT
OF POLICE POWERS I HAD AN
ENQUIRING CLOSING THE LOCAL.
LEVEL- TALKING ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY AND THE SAFETY PART
OF AND PROGRAMS AGAIN I THINK-
MINUS- WASN'T EASY BUT IN THE
EARLY MINDS. I LARGE PERCENT OF
THE- AND THE THIS OF THIS. THAT
WE HAD AND WERE QUITE RECEPTIVE
VERY POSITIVELY RESPONSIVE- I
GAVE OUT THE INFORMATION WHEN.
REAGAN MECHANISM AS AN
INFORMATION MECHANISM AND WE
ALSO PROVIDED SOME PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT I THINK WHERE.
AT A GAME DR WRIST BAND FOR
INSTANCE WE RAN INTO PROBLEMS
IS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE IN MANY
CASES AND NOT JUST THIS
INDUSTRY ANY INDUSTRY AND
ACROSS THE WORLD THIS WASN'T A
CALIFORNIA ISSUE ACROSS THE
ROAD WE DIDN'T. HAVE THE ONS
SAYS. OUR SYSTEM OF THE
QUESTION PEOPLE ARE ASKING. I'M
TO FIND OUT IF THE CAR WAS IN
NEW IS TO THE MOST INFORMED OF
SPREADING THIS PANDEMIC AND
WHEN DID NERVE RATE LATER
REALIZED THAT ERA SOULS AND
TRANSMISSION WAS PROBABLY MORE
IMPORTANT SO THOSE ARE THE SORT
OF THINGS THAT WE HAD TO ADJUST
TO AS MANY AS YOU WENT. ALONG
NEXT I BELIEVE. YEAH PARTY
RELATED TO THE FACT THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE AUDIENCES AT
FEDERAL STATE OR LOCAL LEVEL-
I'M NOT SURE THE INFORMATION
WAS FRAGMENTED AND HE- EVEN
THOUGH WE TRY TO SHARE WHAT
INFORMATION WE HAD WE ALSO HAVE
TO BE COGNIZANT THAT SOMETIMES
PUTTING ON PUTTING INFORMATION
EVEN ADEQUATE INFORMATION WAS A
BAD THING SO AGAIN IT WAS A ONE
OF THOSE BALANCING ACTS. MOST
OF THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH FOLKS HAVE A GOOD
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH SOME
OF THE CHAPTERS OF THE CRA OR
SOME BUSINESS COMMUNITY- GROUP
THAT THEY WORK WITH AS
REGULATORS ACT AS WELL IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AS THE
HAZMAT INDUSTRY OR THE INDUSTRY
THAT CAN REGULATE AND WE
UTILIZE THOSE FOR THE FOR THE-
GROUP THAT I REPRESENT THE
CONFERENCE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH FOLKS WE WERE VERY
FORTUNATE AND PRIVILEGED TO
HAVE IT SOUND WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WAS HERE ARE AND I
THINK MAX AND HIS FOLKS ARE
FOLKS WHO COMMUNICATING
FREQUENTLY WITH FAST. I THINK
THAT REALLY REALLY HELPED. ONLY
ONCE AGAIN- OTHER. YOU KNOW
THERE'S A I THINK THAT
OVERARCHING PROBLEM I'M NOT TOO
SURE COAT IT WAS ALL THROUGH A
Y. WE LISTED EXCESS SEDANS WHEN
A MASSIVE ON WELL BEING THE
BOTTOM LINE BUDGETS ON ON THEIR
FAMILY LIVES THINGS STARTED TO
HIT NOT JUST THIS INDUSTRY BUT
OTHER INDUSTRIES WE STARTED TO
SEE INSTEAD PUSHED BACK AND I
THINK IT'S INEVITABLE YOU KNOW
WE REALIZED IT WAS MORE THAN
THE THREE WEEKS THAT SOME
PEOPLE ANTICIPATED IT WAS
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN MANSON LAUREL
AND WE ANTICIPATED- SHOWS A
TIMELINE AND ALSO WHILE THAT
FRUSTRATION. HE STARTED TO HATE
US- SO NEXT TIME PLEASE. DAX
COMBO. FROM SOME FROM. BECAUSE
SOME BULLET J. SO OF FUN MAN. A
LITTLE BIT OF A- TO HEALTH- I
KNOW THAT THE HEALTH OFFICER
DIDN'T IT DIDN'T- NEW TO DO
LIST. IN AND THAT IS SOMETHING
LIKE EIGHTEEN OF EYE HEALTH
OFFICERS OF EITHER RESIGNED TO
BEING SQUEEZED OUT WELL RETIRED
OR WHATEVER THE CASE IS BUT
ANOTHER LONG DAY IN THEIR
POSITION THAT THEY HELD
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AGO AND THEY WERE UNDER INTENSE
PRESSURE. AND OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH FOLKS WERE UNDER NOT
NECESSARILY THE SAME PRESSURE
BUT THEY CERTAINLY HAD INTENSE
PRESSURE BECAUSE THEY WERE THE
ONES GOING IN AND SHUTTING DOWN
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD AND IS VERY
VERY DIFFICULT. AND WHEN WE
HAVE CONFLICTING VIEWS FROM
OTHERWISE. TRUSTED SOURCES.
WELL THE PRESIDENT WAS. ELSE
FROM MANTA FRESH. WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGE AND I
THINK THAT IS PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST DIFFICULTY WE HAD TO
FACE WHAT IS THIS BACKLASH TO
WORK WITH. HEY REAL RESPECTED
AND WELLNESS UNIVERSITY AND HE
SAID TO DIRECTIVE FROM HEALTH
OUGHT TO STORE HEALTH PERSONNEL
THAT STARTED THE FRAME AROUND
THE AGE SO THAT- THE
FRUSTRATION AND ANGER. HELLO
WHEN WE HAD TO GO IN AND ENSURE
THAT WE- THAT THE- RESTAURANTS
HAD TO CLOSE ALL FOLLOW CERTAIN
PROTOCOLS- AND THEN THE OTHER
THING YOU KNOW TO BE VERY
HONEST AND FRANK ABOUT THE
STADIUM BALDWIN'S. THIS STAGE
STEP IN AND HELP WITH
ENFORCEMENT IT WASN'T ALWAYS ON
THE BACKS OF THE LOCALS AND
GIVE HER SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THEMSELVES DIDN'T
ENFORCE IT FOUND THAT YOU KNOW.
THAT SHERIFF'S OFFICES AND
POLICE OFFICERS DIDN'T GO IN
FIRST WHAT IS BOTH STATE LAW
AND BAD PUBLIC HEALTH MANDATES
SO THAT WAS A REAL CHALLENGE
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. I
THANK YOU JUST SO OPTIMIZATION
KNOW WANT THIS- INTERACT
BALANCED BETWEEN STATE
DIRECTIVES WHICH DOES NOT FIT
THE WORLD DOESN'T STRIKE ME AT
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
NORMAL CITIES IN THE STATE
BAGHDAD STATE DIRECTIVE WAS
CRITICAL WE ALWAYS HAVE THE
INPUT LOOKING FOR BUT ALSO MADE
GAINS WE GOT TO A REASONABLE
BALANCE AND NOW MOVING FORWARD.
WE SEE WHERE WE CAN STRENGTHEN
OUR SOME OF OUR COMMUNICATION.
IS BASED. THE NATIONAL BUT I
CAN ATTEST THAT YEAH AS I'VE
BEEN WITHIN HEALTH. I CAN'T SAY
FROM THE ONLY. I'M ABOUT TO NOT
PERCENT. AND THAT'S NOT
WILLIAMS REST I WANT TO THAT
CLEAR WE HAVE SOME OF THE SAME
FRUSTRATIONS IN THE WORLD.
BECAUSE OF THE INDUSTRY AND
BECAUSE OF OUR OVERSIGHT BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING EVEN THOUGH
I WAS A KID SICK IN THEIR OWN
HOME IT'S VERY. DIFFICULT TO
TRACE PHONE BONELLI'S SOMETIMES
IS VERY MINOR IT'S NOT SEVERE
PEOPLE ARE HOSPITALIZED BUT IT
COULD BE ATTRIBUTED TO SOME
SORT OF. AN ILLNESS IS
INFREQUENTLY REPORTED SO
CONFOUNDING DAD WAS THE LACK OF
EVIDENCE THAT HE HAD TO TAKE. A
RIDE BECAUSE OF IT- WE-
STRUGGLED. STRUGGLE TO EVIDENCE
BASED REGULATION. SO AGAIN I
WANT TO JUST THIS LAST LINE
FROM SOME- FULL NAME HELLO
DEPARTMENTS AND- FURTHER
QUESTIONS PLEASE YOU KNOW SEND
ME A TEXT OR AN EMAIL AND I'LL
GET BACK TO YOU BUT I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING THE
REST OF THE PANEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHIP AND DAN THANK YOU
MISTER MONTGOMERY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY FROM MAKE YOURSELF
AVAILABLE TODAY SO WHAT WE'LL
DO- THE NEXT PANELISTS AND THEN
WE'LL OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM. THE COMMITTEE- THE FINAL
KEY PRESENTER OF OUR OPENING
PANEL THIS IS MATTHEW SUTTON
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION MATT HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN ARRANGING
PERCENTAGE FOR HERE TODAY AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. WE
ALSO PURCHASED WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH MY STAFF- AND LENDERS
ACCESS TO HISEXPERTISE AND
EXPERTISE OF THE INDUSTRY AS A
LEADER AT CRA THAT KNOWS THE
STRUGGLES ALL CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS HAVE FACED AND
CONTINUE TO FACE. AT THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUE TO UNFOLD. WELCOME MR
CERTAIN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR HAS
MEMBERS MATT SUTTON YOUR
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION GOOD TO
SEE HBO- AND FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP- THIS COMMITTEE
CONTINUES TO DO AMAZING
OVERSIGHT WORK- AT ITS
INCEPTION WITH YOU CENTER IN
DALLAS IS CHAIR AND- NOW WITH
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN AT THE HOME-
IN EACH OF YOU. AND VICE CHAIR
BATES SO WE GREATLY APPRECIATED
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE- I
THINK SHE IS AS WE SAID.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY I THINK THE
WORK PRODUCT BEFORE YOU- THE
AGENDA ITSELF AND THE BRIEFING UNDERSCORE WHAT'S WHAT'S
BEEN UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED AND
BOTH YOU CHAIR NEWMAN ADVICE
SHARE BASED. ONE OF THAT OUT OF
THAT IS THAT THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY IS UNLIKE ANY OTHER
EMPLOYMENT COMMUNITY IN THE
STATE IN TERMS OF HOW THIS
IMPACTED. BY THE CODE NINETEEN
CLOSURES. SO WE YOU THINK ABOUT.
THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY I
WOULD ASK YOU TO THINK OF IT IN
TERMS OF THE LARGER RESTAURANT
ECOSYSTEM- AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS THAT OF COURSE INCLUDES
THE BRICK AND MORTAR RESTAURANT
ITSELF. CERTAINLY THE TEAM
MEMBERS BUT THE PURVEYORS AND
SUPPLIERS AS WELL TO THOSE
RESTAURANTS THAT PROVIDE FOOD
AND ALCOHOL LINENS ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES TO RUN A
RESTAURANT- IN THE MANY MANY
MANY GROWERS AND THEIR TEAMS
THAT- ARE PRODUCING AND GROWING
THE FOOD FOR RESTAURANTS. SO
CLOSING RESTAURANTS LITERALLY
REVERBERATES ALL THE WAY BACK
DOWN TO THE SOIL ALL THROUGH
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND INTO THE
GROUND WHERE THE FOOD IS GROWN
AND AT EACH STEP UNFORTUNATELY
WITH RESTAURANT CLOSURES-
THERE'S NATIVE EMPLOYMENT
IMPACTS BUT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE SPOTS ALONG THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. SO OBVIOUSLY. VERY
STRONG AND DECISIVE MEASURES
WERE TAKEN TO CLOSE RESTAURANTS
BACK IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY-
WE'VE HAD SORT OF AN EVIDENCE
FLOW SINCE THEN- AND WE REMAIN-
NOT FULLY OPERATIONAL TODAY-
AND THERE IS OPTIMISM AND I'LL
GET TO THAT SHORTLY- THE ORDER
TO SHUT DOWN RESTAURANTS AND
MEDIA LEE WHAT WAS CERTAINLY-
DECISIVE BUT ALSO YOU KNOW
LOOKING BACK ON IT HAD SOME
CONSEQUENCES- THAT THAT WE CAN
NOW FULLY APPRECIATE AND ONE OF
THOSE WAS YOU KNOW TELLING
OPERATORS IMMEDIATELY THAT THEY
MUST SHUT DOWN- IT LEAVES THEM
WITH NO FLEXIBILITY TO RAMP
DOWN OPERATIONS- IT LEAVES THEM
WITH NO ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY
DISTRIBUTE ALL THAT PRODUCT AND
ALL THAT INVENTORY. OF FRESH
FOOD- THE DAY HAD RECENTLY
PURCHASED- AND THAT'S A COST TO
IT RIGHT IT'S ALSO YOU KNOW
IT'S UNFORTUNATE WASTE MANY
RESTAURANTS PIVOTED AND GOT
THAT FOOD OUT TO THE NEEDY TO
THE HOMELESS OTHERS PROVIDED AS
SORT OF GROCERY TYPE ITEMS AND
DID A LOT OF INNOVATIVE THINGS-
THERE WAS ALSO NO ABILITY TO
SLOW DOWN- THE STAND THE
STAFFING AND THT UNFORTUNATELY
LED TO FORCED. LAYOFFS IN THE
INDUSTRY OR TO SOFTEN THE BLOW
TO THE PURVEYORS ALL OF THOSE
ORDERS WHEN YOU MAGNIFIED
ACROSS THE STATE RESTAURANT
AFTER RESTAURANT AFTER
RESTAURANT THAT'S COUNTLESS
ORDERS IN COUNTLESS PEOPLE IN
THE. SUPPLY CHAIN THAT WERE
IMPACTED AS WELL. SO WE HAVE
ANY RESTAURANTS THERE'S IN
RESTAURANTS AND JEN THROUGHOUT
STATE WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A LONG
STANDING AND GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH HELP US HELP OFFICERS. IN
THE STATE SIXTY TWO DIFFERENT
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. YOU MAY
SAY WAIT WISER SIXTY TWO OUTER
SECTIONS IT'S THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES
BERKELEY- PASADENA BURDEN AND
LONG BEACH EACH HAVE THEIR OWN
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND SO THEY
WERE THE VERY ENTITIES. THAT
WERE PLACED AT THE FOREFRONT OF
MANAGING- THE PANDEMIC CLOSURES
ON THE GROUND. AND I JUST TAKE
A MOMENT DOCTOR WILLIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT AND
EVERYTHING HE SAID ND SO IS MR
MON- BOY. DAD AND THERE'S SO
MANY TOUGH JOBS IN THE
PANDEMIC- CERTAINLY HATS OFF TO
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS BUT BOY
HEALTH OFFICERS WERE IN A TOUGH
SPOT AND WE ALWAYS RECOGNIZE
THAT. EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM
TRYING TO DO THEIR BEST WITH AN
EVOLVING VIRUS THAT THE WORLD
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT SO-
VERY TOUGH AND- YOU KNOW
DECISIONS MADE- ON THE FLY
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO BE MADEON
THE FLY AND THERE'S PLENTY THAT
YOU KNOW. WE IS RESTAURANT
REPRESENTATIVES IN THOSE
OPERATORS DIDN'T ALWAYS AGREE
BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN
APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW THE
VANTAGE POINT THAT THEY HAD IN
THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY
HAD AND STILL HAVE TODAY- SO- I
GUESS. I WOULD JUST MOVE ON TO
YOU KNOW MR LAN REFERENCED THE
CALIFORNIA RETAIL FOOD
COALITION AND THAT'S A TWENTY
YEAR OLD NETWORK OF FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL FOOD SAFETY
OFFICERS REGULATORS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AS WELL AS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE RETAIL
FOOD COMMUNITY INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION SO JUSTIN MR MON
REFERENCED EARLIER THAT WE ALL
HUDDLED- AND CAME UP WITH A
NUMBER OF OPERATING PROTOCOLS.
BECAUSE RESTAURANTS WERE SHUT
DOWN FOR INDOOR DINING MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL CLOSE TO THE END OF MAY
OF TWENTY TWENTY THAT THE FIRST
RE OPENING IN SOME REGIONS THE
CURBS- AND WE WORK TOGETHER
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THAT
RELATIONSHIP- I WOULD SAY THAT
FOOD SAFETY. AND TRAINING
THAT'S OUR GAME THAT'S OUR
WHEEL HOUSE WE'VE ALWAYS DONE
THAT AND WE'VE ALWAYS. BEEN
REGULATED. BY THE- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. SO WE ARE BACK
EQUIPPED TO DO THOSE. GRANTED
THE STATE A. FIFTEEN- BOOKLETS
A VERY PRESCRIPTIVE MEASURES
THE RESTAURANTS HAD TO TAKE IT
TO BE OPEN MANY OF THOSE- CAME
FROM THIS COLLABORATIVE WORK
AND SO WE APPRECIATE OUR WORK
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER
pPROTOCOL CERTAINLY COME WITH
GREAT EXPENSE- AND SO YOU KNOW
WE ROSE TO THE OCCASION WE DID
THEM ALL- I THINK THERE WAS NO
POINT AT RESTAURANTS- WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO ANYTHING BUT-
PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE DINING
PUBLIC AND THEIR TEAM MEMBERS.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THAT DROVE
ALL OF THE DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE. THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC-
AND AGAIN IT POINTS BACK TO
BOTH THE STATE GUIDANCE- AND
THE COUNTY GUIDANCE BECAUSE OF
COURSE THE COUNTIES DO YOU HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ISSUE MORE
RESTRICTIVE GUIDANCE IN THIS
STATE AND IN MOST CASES. THESE
DATA ACT AND- YOU KNOW THAT WAS
WITH THE APPROACH OF SORT OF A
REGIONAL RISK BASED ASSESSMENT-
AND SOME WERE MUCH MORE
RESTRICTIVE. THAN OTHERS
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE. THE
POINT IN ALL THIS- IS THAT IF
YOUR RESTAURANT TOUR YOU HAVE
THESE DIFFERENT LAYERS OF
PROTOCOLS- AND BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE PANDEMIC- YOU
KNOW LOOK THE LANDSCAPE WAS
CONSTANTLY SHIFTING UNDER
EVERYBODY'S FEET BUT
RESTAURANTS IN PARTICULAR- AND
THAT MEANT. THAT HELP OFFICERS
WHETHER AT THE STATE LEVEL OR
THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'RE
CONSTANTLY BEING FACED WITH
THIS VIRUS THAT WAS NEW BY
DEFINITION RIGHT- AND ALSO WAS
OUTSMARTING EVERYBODY
OUTSMARTING THE WORLD. AND SO
THAT WAS I THINK WHAT. MADE A
LOT OF THE PROTOCOLS AND
REQUIREMENTS AND THINGS FOR
RESTAURANTS EVOLVE. OVER TIME.
AND SO AGAIN EVERYONE DID THEIR
BEST WE FULLY APPRECIATE THE
ROLE THE HEALTH OFFICERS AND WE
KNOW WHAT THEY WERE UP AGAINST
AND WE ALSO FELT THAT
IMPLEMENTING SAFETY MEASURES.
GIVEN ALL OF THE FOOD SAFETY
AND OTHER TYPE OF SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE FROM
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
THAT WE DO DAILY WE FELT VERY
VERY EQUIPPED. TO IMPLEMENT
THESE- SO WE PUT OUR BEST FOOT
FORWARD EVERY STEP NO MATTER
THE COST WITH THE PROTECTION OF
OUR TEAM MEMBERS IN THE DINING
PUBLIC ALWAYS DRIVING EVERY
DECISION. SO MANY RESTAURANTS
CONTINUE RUNNING ON THE
ENORMOUS FINANCIAL LOSSES
ACROSS THE BOARD. BUT
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT CAME TO
THE TAKE OUT MODEL- I KNOW
THERE'S THE PERCEPTION THAT
TAKE OUT IS SORT OF THIS THIS
GREAT THING AND FOR MANY
RESTAURANTS THAT IT IS BUT LOTS
OF RESTAURANTS. ACTUALLY DON'T
DO TAKE OUT OR THEIR PRODUCTS
DON'T LEND THEMSELVES TO TAKE
OUT SO IT IS NOT THE BE ALL END
ALL SAVIOR. BUT CAN YOU TALK TO
RESTAURANTS AND THEY TELL ME
THAT I DID THIS AND IT WAS A
HUGE LOSS FINANCIALLY AND I
ASKED THEM WHY. AND THEY SAY
OVER AND OVER AND OVER THEY RAN
UP THESE LOSSES AND THEY DID
TAKE OUT WHEN THAT WASN'T THEIR
THING- TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO TRY TO KEEP ANY
EMPLOYEES ON THE PAYROLL FOR AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE. SO THAT THAT
IS THE AMAZING STORY AND A
GREAT SACRIFICE BUT CERTAINLY.
AN EXAMPLE OF OUR RESTAURANTS
ONCE AGAIN ROSE TO THE OCCASION
SERVED THEIR COMMUNITY AND DID
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO KEEP
EVERY LAST. LATE ON THE PAYROLL.
SO I'VE NEVER SEEN- GREW OF
EMPLOYERS- IN MY TWENTY YEARS
OF WORKING FOR EMPLOYERS- SO
EMPATHETIC. TO OTHER TEAM
MEMBERS- THE COUNTLESS
RESTAURANTS EVERYWHERE AGAIN
THE GRAND CHAPLAIN ACTUAL
LOSSES. TO KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN TO SOME DEGREE EVEN IF IT
WAS JUST FOR A TRICKLE OF
REVENUE TO KEEP STAFF ON. WAS
VERY IMPRESSIVE. AND SO IT WAS
IN IT CONTINUES TO BE OUR
WRENCHING REALLY- BUT I'VE
NEVER SEEN OR BEEN MORE PROUD
TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH SUCH AN
EMPATHETIC HARDWORKING
RESILIENT- AND SCRAPPY WHEN
NEEDED- TO KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN GROUP OF EMPLOYERS- SO AS
WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER THAT
TODAY. NO WHERE IN THE STATE IN
A RESTAURANT FULLY OPERATES-%
AND THIS IS BEEN THE CASE SINCE
THE END OF LAST AUGUST
BEGINNING OF SEPTEMBER- AND
THEN PLACES LIKE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND OTHERS IT'S BEEN
EVEN LONGER- AND FOR INDOOR
OPERATIONS IN FULL CAPACITY
THERE'S NO FULL CAPACITY
ALLOWED ANYMORE. WE'VE SPENT
THE LAST YEAR HUDDLED AROUND
EVERY TUESDAY WAITING FOR THE
STATE ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT THE
FATE OF RESTAURANT OPERATIONS
IN EACH COUNTY- AND THAT
TUESDAY CADENCE CONTINUES. UP
UNTIL TODAY AND WILL UNTIL JUNE
FIFTEENTH PRESUMABLY. SO WE'VE
KIND OF OPERATED AS THE
ASSOCIATION LIKE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROL OR LIKE FOOTBALL
QUARTERBACK YOU TAKING THESE
PLAYS ARE DIRECTIVES FROM THE
STATE AND COUNTY. PASSING THEM
ON TO RESTAURANTS ON THE GROUND
IN EVERY POCKET OF THE STATE SO
THAT THEY COULD HAVE IT
IMMEDIATELY TO THE ORDER
FLUCTUATIONS OF THEIR
OPERATIONS AND MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS. SO WITH THE FAIR
APPARENT FULL RE OPENING COME
JUNE FIFTEENTH. VERY EXCITED WE
THINK THAT THERE'S DEFINITELY-
OPTIMISM IN THE AIR- BUT I
WOULD HOWEVER CAUTION THAT RE
OPENING IS THE FIRST MILE OF
THE REALLY LONG. ROAD AHEAD TO
RECOVERY FROM THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT RESTAURANTS
STATEWIDE AGAIN I'VE BEEN
FORCED TO OPERATE IT
UNSUSTAINABLE LEVELS FOR OVER A
YEAR MEANWHILE THOSE FIXED
COSTS INSURANCE BRANDS AND ALL
SORTS OF OTHER THINGS-
CONTINUED TO BUILD THE ENTIRE
TIME THEY WERE CLOSE- AND SO
THAT THAT RECKONING IS GONNA
COME TO RESTAURANTS- FINANCIAL
RECKONING. RESTAURANTS ARE
GONNA NEED A LONG RUNWAY TO
PREPARE FOR A SUCCESSFUL TAKE
OFF AND IT'S GONNA BE CRITICAL
THAT THERE'S NOT ANY DEGREE IN
THE RUNWAY AND THAT INCLUDES
POLICIES THAT ARE WELL INTENDED
THAT MAY HINDER THAT RECOVERY.
IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER THE
SIZE OF A RESTAURANT. THEY ALL
HAD TO NAVIGATE THE OSCILLATING
SET OF OPERATING RULES- IT AND
THEY WERE IMPACTED EQUALLY BY
ALL OF THE PROTOCOLS AND
RESTRICTIONS ON OTHER BUSINESS
MODEL. EVEN SMALL RESTAURANTS
ARE REALLY REALLY LABOR
INTENSIVE. MANY MANY MANY
PEOPLE OCCUPY SMALL RESTAURANTS
IN TERMS OF. MAKING A RUN ON A
DAILY BASIS RESTAURANTS ARE
OFTEN SIZED UP BY HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES THEY HAPPEN WE WOULD
JUST CAUTION YOU NOT TO DO THAT
BECAUSE EVEN THE SMALLEST OF
RESTAURANTS. I HAVE QUITE A
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES.
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES
IN CLIFORNIA WERE LAID OFF OR
FURLOUGHED BETWEEN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY AND THAT AUGUST.
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS AS YOU
KNOW FROM YOUR DISTRICT OF THE
CORNERSTONE OF EVERY COMMUNITY
AND 60% OF CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS ARE OWNED BY PEOPLE
OF COLOR. RESPECTING THE
AMAZING DIVERSITY OF THE STATE.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WAS AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT EMPLOYS ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION. SERVICE WORKERS
AND GENERATED MORE SALES TAX IN
ANY INDUSTRY. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO BUILDING BACK TO THAT BUT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS AND IT'S GONNA TAKE
PROACTIVE POLICIES ACTUALLY
LIKE CONSIDERING RETURN TO WORK
INCENTIVES AND OTHER THINGS
THAT MAY HELP RESTAURANTS GET
THROUGH. THE FINANCIAL CRASH
THAT'S COMING IN SOME OF THOSE.
FINANCIAL ITEMS THAT HAVE BUILT
UP OVER THE OVER THE YEAR WITH
THE CLOSURES. SO AGAIN YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM RESTAURANTS
THEY'RE GONNA SAY IT'S BEST WE
REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION. TO THIS ISSUE AND TO
THE INDUSTRY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH EACH OF
YOU CENTERS ON- YOU KNOW%
GETTING BACK TO GETTING BACK TO
NORMAL BUT ALSO GETTING BACK TO
THE DRAWING. OUT THE MOST
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
GENERATING THE MOST SALES TAX
REVENUE FOR THE STATE SO WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND- I APPRECIATED VERY MUCH.
AND I THANK YOU MUCH CENSORED
THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOUR YOUR- POINTS
ARE EXTREMELY WELL TAKEN RIGHT
TO RESTAURANTS OCCUPY KIND OF
ENTRY INTERESTING PLACE IN OUR-
CULTURE- THEY ARE UBIQUITOUS-
WE TAKE THEM FOR GRANTED
SOMETIMES BUT BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THEY'RE NOT REALLY
CHALLENGING BUSINESSES- AND THE
PANDEMIC IS MADE THAT. EVEN
HARDER SO AT THIS POINT I'D
LIKE TO OPEN UP THE QUESTION OF
SENATOR ROTH YOU HAD. A
QUESTION- PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
YOU MR CHAIR. THE FACT THAT THE-
TITLE OF THIS PANEL INCLUDES
THE PHRASE PERSPECTIVES ON
IMPLEMENTATION I LIKE TO FOLLOW
UP ON. THE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS OF MY FRIEND THE
SENATOR FROM FRESNO YOU KNOW I
COME FROM INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE WAS A LOT
OF CONTROVERSY. OVER THE
RESTAURANT OPERATING
RESTRICTIONS DURING THE- THE
CODE PANDEMIC OF NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SO FAR. A FULL
CLOSURES PARTIAL CLOSURES. 25%
OCCUPANCY 50% OCCUPANCY AND OF
COURSE. WHETHER THOSE
OPERATIONAL RESTRICTIONS WERE
REQUIRED WHETHER THEY WERE.
PROPRIOCEPTION AND EVEN WHETHER
THEY WERE EFFECTIVE IN
PREVENTING THE TRANSMISSION OF
DISEASE SO TO SPECIFICALLY
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUE'S
QUESTION- ARE WE ABLE TO
DETERMINE OR ARE WE NOT ABLE TO
DETERMINE TRANSMISSION RATES.
IN RESTAURANTS IN THE
RESTAURANT SETTINGS VERSUS
OTHER SETTINGS LIKE BIG BOX
RETAIL STORES AND SOME OF THE
OTHER. CONSUMER INTERFACES THAT
WAS WE'RE GOING ON DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. WHETHER INDOOR OR
OUTDOOR ON A STATEWIDE BASIS.
IS THAT. THE QUESTION FOR ME
ANYONE WHO CAN ANSWER IT. YEAH
I CAN I CAN START- WE DO HAVE-
YOUR EVIDENCE FROM FROM ACROSS
THE NATION OF OUTBREAKS OF
COVERT NINETEEN FACTUAL IT DID
ORIGINATE IN INDOOR DINING
ESTABLISHMENTS THERE'S A
MORBIDITY MORTALITY WEEKLY
REPORT NOTED WE ARE WHICH IS
THE CDC'S. WEEKLY WEEKLY
LITERATURE IN TERMS OF-
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND IT'S-
THERE WAS A SORT OF A SEMINAL-
STUDY THAT SHOWED THERE WAS A
SUPER SPREADER EVENT THAT
OCCURRED IN A RESTAURANT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE- THERE WASN'T
ADEQUATE VENTILATION IT WAS
INDOORS. IT WAS ONE INDIVIDUAL-
WHO THROUGH THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO CONTACT THE VERY
AGGRESSIVE CONTACT TRACING. SS
EIGHTEEN OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO
WITHIN THAT RESTAURANT WHEN IT
GETTING INFECTED JUST BY HAVING
BEEN IN THERE FOR ABOUT A TWO
HOUR PERIOD WITH THIS ONE
INDIVIDUAL- AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER THAT WAS THE MOST
DRAMATIC THERE'S BEEN OTHER.
OTHER EVIDENCE OF TRANSMISSION
WITHIN WITHIN RESTAURANTS I
THINK ALL OF US AT THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER LEVEL IT IN OUR
CONTACT TRACING. HOW FOUNTAINS
ONE OF THE REASONS WE
PRIORITIZED A WORKING AT THE
RESTAURANT FOR TESTING THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND B. VACCINATION
ONCE ONCE YOU KNOW ONCE
RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES BECAME. A
PRIORITY GROUP- FOODS FOOD
SERVICE SECTOR WAS WIDELY PLACE
AND ONE OF THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED
BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF
INFECTION IN THAT SETTING. IT'S
A- KLAY UNDERSTANDABLE JUST
BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE KNOW
THE TRANSMISSION OCCURS.
BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS ARE CLOSE
TOGETHER. OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
WHEN THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO COVER
THEIR FACES AND SO THAT'S THE-
THAT'S THE CHARACTERISTIC OF AN
INDOOR DINING S. EXPERIENCE.
THAT IS CONCERNING FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT AND
THAT FURTHERMORE WE HAVE HAVE
WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF
TRANSMISSION IN THAT SETTING MY
COMMENTS REGARDING. THAT THE
PAUCITY OF EVIDENCE AROUND THE
HARM OF OUTDOOR DINING IS A
DIFFERENT QUESTION AND THAT
REMAINS A QUESTION MARK IN MY
MIND- BUT I HAVE NO GOOD NO
DOUBT FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDPOINT. OF THE OF THE NEED
FOR- REGULATIONS AROUND DINING.
WHEN THE BUYER IS. PRESENT AND
IN THE IN COMMUNITIES CERTAINLY.
OXIDATION HERE I THINK
EVERYTHING. WHEN WE HAVE BACKS
RATES WHICH WHEN YOU'RE DOWN
AND ENTER INTO YOU UNDER. THE
OF THE- IN THAT IN. WHEN THE
REST TO THE QUESTION IS
ANECDOTAL DATA AS OPPOSED TO.
SCIENTIFIC AND STATISTICAL DATA.
THEN I GUESS MY CONCERN I
UNDERSTAND IT THE SINCE WE
HAVEN'T HAD ONE OF THESE THINGS
AND OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AS HE
SETS MY RECOLLECTION IN THE
UNITED STATES. I CAN UNDERSTAND
THE- LACK OF ORGANIZATION TO
COLLECT AND COLLATE DATA AT THE
BEGINNING. I'M GOING TO BE LESS
UNDERSTANDING AS WE MOVE TO THE
HOPEFULLY LOGICAL CONCLUSION OF
THIS PANDEMIC SOON I HOPE. IF
WE DON'T HAVE A BETTER HANDLE
ON. STATISTICAL DATA AND
ANALYSIS WHEN IT COMES TO.
TICKETS EARLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
TODAY WHAT THE TRANSMISSION
RATE IS FROM A STATISTICAL
BASIS DATA THAT CAN WITHSTAND
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS BOTH PRO
AND CON AND ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION ABOUT A SINGLE
RESTAURANT WITH EIGHTEEN.
INDIVIDUALS WHO- WHO CAME DOWN
THE CALL THAT IF THAT WAS THE
NUMBER. REALLY DOESN'T CUT THE
MUSTARD WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW THE PARTICULAR RESTAURANT
THE VENTILATION SYSTEM THAT'S
WHY THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME.
SORT OF STATISTICS THAT'S
COMPILED AND ANALYZED SO THAT
WE CAN SORT OF LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE NEXT TIME
WE HAVE ONE OF THESE I'M SURE I
WON'T BE AROUND BUT- WHEN WE
DO. SOMEONE CAN MAKE A LOGICAL
DECISION AT THE VERY BEGINNING
HOPEFULLY WE SHUT THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY DOWN. DO WE GO 225%
CAPACITY AND DOOR BECAUSE THE
STATISTICS SAY BUT THE CHANCES
OF TRANSMISSION WHEN THERE'S
ENOUGH SPACING AND THE
OCCUPANCY IS RESTRICTED 225% OR
MINIMAL OR DEMAND OF MISS. AM I
MAKING SENSE. AND DO WE HAVE
HAD SORT OF STATISTICAL DATA
AVAILABLE TO US. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TODAY. AND IF
NOT. MAY WE AS LEGISLATORS
EXPECT TO SEE THAT. BY THE END
OF THE YEAR OR BY THE END OF
NEXT YEAR RELATED O THE CALL
OF A NINETEEN. TEN DAMAGE. MAY
I RESPOND TO AS A REGULATOR.
PLEASE DO PLEASE. I WANT TO
REINFORCE THE DOCTOR WILL
ASSESS AND I AM NOT A PHYSICIAN
I'M MOST ONLINE BUYING THE HOME
FOLKS ARE NOT PHYSICIANS AND WE
RELIED VERY HEAVILY ON OUR-
PHYSICIANS. PARENTS AND OTHERS
TO MAKE THOSE JUDGMENT CALLS
BUT THEIMPORTANT PONT. THIS
WHOLE REGIME RESPONSE FROM A
REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE WASN'T
BASED ON ANECDOTE. BASED ON
VERY VERY SOUND PUBLIC HEALTH
PRINCIPLES. YOU CAN TRANSPOSE
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH PRINCIPLES
IF YOU HAVE A DISEASE THAT'S
SPREADING AND TRIED TO ARREST
THE SPREAD OF THAT DISEASE. MAY
NOT HAVE HAD A RIDE ON SINCE WE
MAY NOT HAVE. TIME TO DO ALL
RIGHT THINGS BUT REMEMBER THIS
WAS TIME. VIRUS CORRECT FOR
THEM. PRINT OF TO RESPOND THIS.
AND I THINK THE FANS TO.
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS THE I WORKING
SHELDON THIS INDUSTRY. HE'S
TRYING TO OPEN UP. THEY CAN DO
IT SAFELY THAT WAS PRETTY. THE
MOST IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. ONCE AGAIN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR NOBODY WANTS
THE RESTAURANT STUFF TO BE SICK
SO I WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WASN'T THIS. ANECDOTAL SORT OF
SUCKING IT OUT OF THE SUN THIS
IS HOW WE SHOULD GO ABOUT IT
THIS IS THE RISK. WE FOLLOW THE
SAME BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH. CALLS
FOR STOPPING INDUSTRIES AND
THIS IS WHAT WE WERE GIVEN BOTH
OF US LISTEN DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND ME. YOU MAY NOT
BE THE RIGHT PANEL HERE FOR ME
TO ASK HIS QUESTION. I'M NOT
BEING CRITICAL OF WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE DURING THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHAT I'M
SINCE ITS PERSPECTIVES ON
IMPLEMENTATION WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT. IS SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT HAVING
BEEN THROUGH THIS AS TRAGIC AS
THIS HAS BEEN. FOR EVERYONE
INCLUDING THOSE FAMILIES WHO
HAVE LOST INDIVIDUALS TO COVER
NINETEEN. I WOULD HOPE TAT
WE'RE FIGURING OUT HOW TO
COLLECT DATA TO. MAYBE CONFIRM
THAT THE DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE DURING THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WERE THE
APPROPRIATE ONES. AND TO SET A
STANDARD FOR RESPONDING TO A
FUTURE PANDEMIC THAT WAS THE
REASON I WAS ASKING ABOUT THE
DATA COLLECTION. R. N. AND IF
THE ANSWER IS WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING IT THEN I GUESS
WE'LL GET THROUGH COVERT
NINETEEN AS A CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WILL FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HAVE A MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATION WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR DATA
COLLECTION TO DETERMINE HOW WE
FIX THIS THING. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IN THE FUTURE WE SHOULD
HAVING BEEN THROUGH THIS I
WOULD THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
DATA. THEY WOULD INFORM OUR
FUTURE PROTOCOLS AND FUTURE
DECISIONS SHOULD WE FACE ONE OF
THESE. PANDEMICS IN THE FUTURE
BUT- PLEASE DON'T MISUNDERSTAND
ME I'M NOT I'M NOT CRITICIZING
THE- PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY OR
ANYONE ELSE. IN TERMS OF THE
RESPONSE TO THIS COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC YOU KNOW
AFTER ALL. NONE OF US WERE
AROUND A HUNDRED PLUS YEARS AGO
WHEN WE HAD THE LAST ONE SO.
YOUR TERM WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL
ENTITLED TO BE TO BE CUT SOME
SLACK ON MEDICINE THANK YOU FOR
DOING THE JOB YOU DID I THINK
I'M GOING TO CLOSE WITH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THAT THAT'S A
STRONG CLOSE IN A ROW SO-
THROUGH THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
I AND I'M SURE WE'LL GET. SOME
ADDITIONAL PERSPECTIVES ON OUR
NEXT PANEL- THE NEXT THE
CEREMONY I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE AT FIRST FOR
CLOSING WITH THE FACT THAT WE
DO NEED MORE DATA TO DETERMINE.
YOU KNOW SHOULD THIS EVER
HAPPENED AGAIN WHAT WE WOULD DO
IT YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF- YOU
KNOW. PROBLEMS AND REMEDIES WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO OFFER TO ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS. YOU KNOW I
COME FROM A FAMILY WHERE I HAVE-A LOT OF CLOSE RELATIVES WHO
ARE IN THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS
AND- WHAT I WITNESSED WAS. A
SINCERE STRUGGLE. VERY SINCERE-
STRUGGLED TO KEEP THEIR
BUSINESS OPENED BUT ALSO DO
RIGHT FOR EMPLOYEES- AND IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT I THINK YOU
WATCH MANY DIFFERENT
RESTAURANTS OF DIFFERENT SIZES-
A DIFFERENT BUSINESS MODELS AND
MANAGE THIS PANDEMIC IN A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY. AND THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK MR
SUTTON SAID THAT STRUCK MY
ATTENTION THAT WE KNOW THAT IF
A LITTLE OVER OR SOMETHING AND
I THINK I GOT THIS RIGHT NINE
THOUSAND- EMPLOYEES WERE LAID
OFF BY RESTAURANTS IN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT MANY
MANY MANY RESTAURANTS DID THEIR
ABSOLUTE BEST TO KEEP S. STAFF
ON AND I KNOW HAT YOU'RE I MY
FAMILY THAT WAS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. YOU ALSO
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE
POTENTIALLY WORK INCENTIVES TO
TRY TO GET FOLKS TO COME BACK
INTO THE INDUSTRY. ANECDOTALLY
I THINK AS THINGS ARE OPENING
UP WE ARE HEARING THAT- SOME
RESTAURANTS ARE SHORT STAFFED
AGAIN BECAUSE THE BUSINESS
MODEL IS VERY DIFFERENT FOR ALL
RESTAURANTS LIKE. RESTAURANTS
AND ALL THE SAME AND- I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
SOME OF THOSE INCENTIVES OR I'M
NOT SURE IF ANOTHER PANEL IS
GOING TO COVER SOME OF THOSE
INCENTIVES BUT I'D LOVE TO HEAR
SPECIFIC IF THERE ARE ANY-
PARTICULARLY AS THE RANGE FOR
THE DIFFERENT TYPES. OF
RESTAURANTS- CENTER IF YOU CAN
REACH ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR IF THIS
IS GONNA BE ON IT. COMING AT
ALL. AND I BELIEVE IT'S A
QUESTION FOR MR SUTTON. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR SENATOR MONA
CREATED QUESTION- AND THE
COMMENTS- ON IT AND YOU KNOW
JUST TO UNDERSCORE THE JOB LOSS
THAT OCCURRED IN THE RESTAURANT
SECTOR WAS NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- AND THAT WAS THAT WAS
A SHORT TIME PERIOD AND AGAIN
THAT THAT'S DUE TO THE ABRUPT
NATURE OF THE DIRECTIVES TO TRY
TO RESTAURANTS- IT IN SO. TO
GET TO YOUR POINT ABOUT RE
HIRING YES WE'RE THAT'S ALL
WE'RE HEARING IT'S A NATIONAL
ISSUE. NOT LIMITED TO THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY IT'S A
IT'S A BROADER REACTION AND YOU
KNOW I DON'T HAVE ANY FORMAL
PROPOSAL- TO SUGGEST ONE THING
THAT YOU KNOW RESTAURANTS
CONTINUE TO SAY TO ME. AND THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS YOU KNOW
THAT THE STATE. IS IN THE SALES
BEEN BLESSED WITH WITH ABUNDANT
REVENUE- I READ YOU MAY NOT
EVEN BE THAT WORK BUT HE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO. TACKLE A NUMBER
OF ISSUES AND THERE'S LOTS OF
PROPOSALS THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PUT TOGETHER IN THE U. S.
LEGISLATORS TO PUT TOGETHER.
FOR HOW THAT SHOULD BE SPENT
AND THEN THE BIG DECISIONS IN
THE COMING WEEKS ONE THING THAT
WE CONTEMPLATE IS. YOU KNOW
THERE HAVE BEEN STIMULUS CHECKS
THERE HAVE BEEN ONE TIME
PAYMENTS AND THERE HAVE BEEN
THOSE KINDS OF RELIEF EFFORTS.
FOR THE UNEMPLOYED AND WE
CONTEMPLATE SHOULD SOME SUCH A
THING EXISTS ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. TO INCENTIVIZE EMPLOYEES
TO GO BACK INTO. THE JOB MARKET
AND I WANTED THE JOB STAND
AFTER THEY- YOU KNOW HAVE THAT
JOB FOR APPEARED OF TIME WOULD
BE A ONE TIME STIMULUS OR TYPE
OF. SIMILAR TYPE OF PAYMENT
WOULD IT MAKE SENSE- BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST AT
THE BEGINNING OF FEELING THIS
CRUNCH OF THE DIFFICULTY OF.
EMPLOYING IN HIRING PEOPLE AND
I THINK THE RESTAURANTS ON THE
NEXT PANEL- MAY BE ABLE TO
TOUCH ON THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE. FOR YOU BUT I APPRECIATE
IT. AND THANK YOU MR SENATE AND
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT CEREMONY
THERE IS A GOOD QUESTION TO WE
ACTUALLY INVITED. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS
FAKE- IN THIS HEARING
SPECIFICALLY WITH WITH AN EYE
TOWARD. THAT QUESTION AND THEY
WERE TOO BUSY APPARENTLY THEY
DECLINED TO PARTICIPATE. SO.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT SAYS-
MANY OTHER. FROM THE PANEL. A
GOOD BOARD JUST. THEN I PAULA
THIS IS SUCH A- IMPORTANT ISSUE.
OF FOR ALL OF US- I HAPPEN TO
SPEND A GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME.
DURING THE MEETING HIM THE
PANDEMIC WORKING ON. RESTAURANT
WITH RELATED MATTERS. MAYBE
I'LL POSE IT THIS QUESTION TO
MR SUTTON. AND I HARKEN BACK-
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE
WAS WAS TALKING ABOUT- WHAT WE
HAVE TO LEARN. BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO BRING- TO BEAR- LESSONS FROM
THE PANDEMIC SO THAT WE ARE
BETTER PREPARED THE NEXT TIME
WHETHER IT IS. A VIRUS OR SOME
OTHER- NATURAL ORGANIC
CATASTROPHE- JUST A QUICK SIDE
NOTE- WHEN I DID ASK. A VARIETY
OF HEALTH OFFICERS IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES ELEVEN
COUNTY SO IT'S PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT- NONE OF THEM
ACTUALLY HAD STATS OR DATA.
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR AN
UNDERSTANDING OF TRANSMISSION
RATES BASED ON INDUSTRY. AND SO
ON A CONFERENCE CALL WHERE MANY
LEGISLATORS WERE PARTICIPATING-
THE QUESTION WAS POSED TO. DR
KELLY. IN THE RESPONSE WAS
PUBLIC POLICIES BEING MADE.
BASED ON THE PATHOLOGY AND
BEHAVIOR OF THE VIRUS. AND I
AND I UNDERSTOOD- YOU KNOW WHY
THAT WAS THE CASE BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT WE DO NEED
METRICS WE DO NEED DATA IN
THOSE FINER POINTS SO THAT WE
CAN BETTER APPRECIATE. HOW TO
TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION- WITH A
SCALPEL INSTEAD OF A BROAD
SWORD WHICH GETS ME TO MY POINT
HERE TO MR SUTTON. TWO POINTS
THAT I THINK I'D LIKE YOUR
COMMENTS ON- DO YOU THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IN A FUTURE
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE. THE MET
THE LEGAL MECHANISM FOR THERE
TO BE EMERGENCY ALTERNATIVES
PUT INTO PLACE AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE
WENT INTO SHUT DOWN FOR THE
INTERMITTENT SHUTDOWNS
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU WERE IN
THE STATE- RESTAURANTS. IN BARS
IN SOME INSTANCES WERE ALLOWED
TO IMMEDIATELY USE. THE
SIDEWALKS. AND THE PARKING
FACILITIES ADJACENT. TO EXTEND
THEIR SERVICES INTO THOSE AREAS
SO THAT THEY WOULD BE OPEN AIR-
SCENARIOS. SHOULD THERE SHOULD
WE BE RECOMMENDING THAT THERE
BE CERTAIN EMERGENCY
ALTERNATIVES- PUT INTO PLACE BY
LEGISLATION OR EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY. THAT WOULD ALLOW
THAT TO OCCUR ACROSS THE STATE
AND ALL POINT TO SAN DIEGO IS
PROBABLY BEING ONE OF THE
LEADERS. IN THE IN DOING THAT.
THE DAY AFTER THE PAYMENT OF
ONE THE SHUTDOWNS OCCURRED AND
THE SECOND. IS THAT NOT ALL
RESTAURANTS ARE IDENTICAL.
CANNOT OVERSTATE THE OBVIOUS
BUT ONE RESTAURANT IN
PARTICULAR IN FRESNO COUNTY. IS
DESIGNED IT AS LARGE AS THIS
WHOLE- BYE AND IT IS COMPLETELY
OPEN. MEANING IT'S GOT WINDOWS
ALL AROUND BUT HAS IT ROOFTOP.
ESSENTIALLY IT IS AN OPEN AIR
RESTAURANT. THERE WAS LITTLE
FLEXIBILITY SHOWN TO THE OWNER
OF THIS RESTAURANT WHO WAS
BRINGING AND SCIENTISTS IN
PERSONS KNOWLEDGEABLE ON- ON ON
HOW TO DEAL WITH VIRUSES. DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD ALSO
HAVE EMERGENCY- LEGAL
ALTERNATIVES FOR FOLKS IN THE
INDUSTRY BUT IF THEY CAN
DEMONSTRATE. THAT THEY ARE
SATISFYING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS. IN THE PROTOCOLS THAT
EXIST WHETHER BE THROUGH
VENTILATION OR BY ARCHITECTURE
AND DESIGN THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THE FREEDOM TO OPEN
UP. IN A DIFFERENT CAPACITY
THAN A COMPLETELY CLOSED SMALL
OPERATIONS OF YOUR COMMENTS AND
THOSE TWO HAD APPRECIATED. IT
OR JUST A PREVIEW OF THE
QUESTION YES- I THINK THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES AND I THINK WE
LEARNED A LOT A NUMBER OF
THINGS- ABOUT THE VIRUS IN AS
WE LEARNED THAT AEROSOL
TRANSMISSION WAS A BIGGER
CONCERN IT MEANT THAT THOSE
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTS BECAME
MUCH MUCH MUCH MORE ESSENTIAL-
AND THAT WAS A PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE BUT IT WAS ALSO A
LIFELINE FOR RESTAURANTS
DISCONTINUE DISTURB THE PUBLIC.
AND KEEP THEIR STAFF ON BOARD
SO I THINK WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT
THE LARGER QUESTION AND I THINK
WE LEARNED SOME GOOD THINGS AND
I THINK WE LEARNED THAT YOU
KNOW EXPANDING OUTDOOR
FOOTPRINTS- YET YOU KNOW WITH
SOME MODERNIZATION- AND
GUARDRAILS AROUND IT IT IS
SENSIBLE IT'S SO SENSIBLE. THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR THAT TO BE
CONTINUED FOR A LITTLE BIT
LONGER VS IN LEGISLATION- AND
WE WOULD ARGUE THAT IN THOSE
CASES IT ACTUALLY MIGHT MAKE
SENSE PERMANENTLY BUT TO GET TO
YOUR QUESTION ABSOLUTELY WE
HAVE LEARNED THAT THOSE THINGS
ARE GOOD COMMUNITIES LIKE THEM
AND THEY CAN BE DONE WITH GOOD
PUBLIC HEALTH. PROTOCOLS AND IT
CAN BE DONE WITH PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY SO YES ON THAT
FRONT- AND WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT
AIR FLOW AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE YES I THINK WE'VE ALSO
LEARNED IN THIS THAT AIRBORNE
TRANSMISSION OF. THIS DISEASE-
WHAT WAS THE MAIN CONCERN. AND
OFTEN RESTAURANTS. HE KNOW HAVE
A LOT OF A- AND RESTRICT ON
THEM. WHAT CAN AND CANNOT
HAPPEN WHEN IT COMES TO OPEN
AIR FLOW- AND SO- I KNOW A
NUMBER OF INSTANCES WHERE
PEOPLE WERE JUST TRYING TO
INCREASE THE AIRFLOW IN THEIR
RESTAURANT. THE HELP. ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTIVE BASIS-
AND THAT IS FOR BED AND- AND SO
SOME OF THOSE ARE BEING LOOKED
AT IT BEING RELAXED IN
LEGISLATION. TO CONTINUE- THAT
FLEXIBILITY AT LEAST FOR THE
NEXT LITTLE WHILE AND THERE'S
TWO BILLS IN PARTICULAR AND ONE
BASICALLY SAYS. YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE THESE THINGS
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR CREW. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THESE THINGS FOR ONE
YEAR AFTER THE PANDEMIC STATE
OF EMERGENCY- YOU KNOW GOES
AWAY- SO. LONG ANSWER THE
ANSWER IS YES TO BOTH. AND
AFTER SHE HAD. APPRECIATE THAT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
PANEL. SURE DOT. I THINK I
MIGHT WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ON THIS
JUST. BRIEFLY I THINK HE- IT'S
EASIER RETRO. TO HE'LL COME UP
WITH YOU KNOW WITH THE PLANET
ONCE AGAIN. YOU'RE NOT TO BE
DEFENSIVE OF THE DECISIONS WERE
MADE. BUT AT THE SAME TIME TO
RECOGNIZE. THERE IS NO PLAYBOOK
AND I THINK MAYBE WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING HERE IS FROM A TOP
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT. IS
THERE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
MOVING FORWARD. TO DEVELOP A
KIND OF PLAYBOOK FOR PANDEMIC
TYPE OF SITUATION. YEAH IN THE
FUTURE I THINK IT'S PRETTY
TOUGH TO- GET A BIG STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA WITH FORTY. MILLION
PEOPLE TO BE GIVING FREE PASSES
TO SADDAM AND NOT TO THE OTHERS
AND- IT CREATES AS MANY
PROBLEMS AS IT IT SOLVES THE
FIRST PLACE. I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF THE HEALTH DIRECTORS
WANT TO. COMMENT ON THAT LAST
QUESTION. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
PRACHANDA. OKAY LET ME ADD TO
IT I'M SURE THIS FOR MR MANOJ
TO SOME GOOD QUESTION. FOR YOU
AT YOUR AGE SO WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE PUSHED ET DE FAIRLY
HARD TO. BE BETTER PREPARED FOR
THE NEXT RECESSION- MYSTERON
YOU MENTION THAT YOU KNOW YOU
YOU HAVE THERE ARE PRICING NINE
HUNDRED STAFF COLLECTIVELY
ACROSS STATE DOING. ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH THE ENFORCEMENT. YOU
KNOW THAT'S CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH.
IN IN A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
SO ALSO LIKE YOUR THOUGHTS AS
YOU RESPONDED DONE. AS TO HOW
TO HOW TO PLAN BETTER FOR THE
KIND OF SURGE. IN CAPACITY THAT
WILL BE NEEDED- IN THE EVENT.
OF A SIMILAR HEALTH EMERGENCE.
RIGHT I MUST REFERRED TO THE
DOG. IN THE WRONG. BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ON BEHALF OF THE
RATE. AND AS I SAID WE TAKE ON
GUIDANCE. THE DOCKS- THAT WE
SHOULD. HAVE TO STRENGTHEN OUR-
CAPACITY IN LOCAL AND STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE. IN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH IS THAT A LOT. OF
PROGRAMS ON A FEW SUPPORTED.
GENERAL JOHN TENNIS NOT A
NAGGING SESSION. I THINK IT'S
JUST AN OBSERVATION I BELIEVE
THE HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE
PROPOSALS TO GAIN GOING HAND
SAYING OUR CAPACITY TO DO
AROUND JUST LIKE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AND I DIDN'T MEAN
TO BE OVERLY DEFENSIVE. IN MY
LAST RESPONSE BECAUSE I DO
THINK THAT. WE ARE ABSOLUTELY.
SO ASKED HAVE THE NAME BECAUSE-
GOOD TO HAVE HIM CURRY COOL
DATA. TYPES OF DISEASES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE DIFFERENT THAT
ARE GOING TO REQUIRE A
DIFFERENT RESPONSE IS GOING TO
BE AROUND A CHALLENGING BUT I.
SEE FOR ADDITIONAL FOR ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH IN GENERAL STATE
AND LOCAL DEVELOP THE CAPACITY
WHICH WE CURRENTLY DOESN'T
HAVE. YOU KNOW Y'ALL CORRECT
YES MA'AM DON'T HAVE ANY
EMPIRICAL DATA TO HOLD UP AND
SHOW THE REGULATED COMMUNITY IN
SOME CASES AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE TO RELY ON COMMON MEDICAL
SESSIONS AND PROTOCOLS AND
IMPENDING ALLERGY IT'S CETERA.
FINANCIAL THAT WE DOING THE
BEST THAT WE CAN. BUT I THINK
DOCTOR WAS MADE NOW TO EXPLAIN
WHAT CAPACITY WHEN TRYING TO
DEVELOP TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
BROADER CAPABILITIES FOR THE
NEXT. TIME WHICH HOPEFULLY ONE
COME. YEAH THANK YOU- YEAH I
AGREE I MEAN I THAT'S- THAT'S A
QUESTION ROSS STRUGGLING WITH
AT THIS POINT NOW AS WE START
TO EMERGE OUT OF THIS I THINK
WE'RE ALL. ALL LOOKING AT THE
AT THE LESSONS LEARNED IN
DIFFERENT SECTORS TODAY'S YOU
KNOW TALKING ABOUT RESTAURANTS
BUT IT'S REALLY. THIS IS THE
SAME CONVERSATION IS HAPPENING
ACROSS DIFFERENT SECTORS AND I
WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW THE
QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP AROUND.
DATA NE OF THE ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY OF.
ATTRIBUTION OF TRANSMISSION HAS
OCCURRED IN ONE SITTING VERSUS
ANOTHER IS THAT IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK FORCE- HAS DESIGNED
FOR PRE PANDEMIC TIMES IN MY
STAFF. ACCOUNT INTO A FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE FIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES THAT ARE
DOING TO REGULUS IS HIV
HEPATITIS C. CONTACT
INVESTIGATIONS. OVER NINETEEN-
AND THE CASELOAD LITERALLY AND
INCREASES BY ONE HUNDRED FOLD I
MEAN IT'S NOT A LITTLE INCREASE
RIGHT TO USE A RESTAURANT AN
ALLERGY LIKE IF YOU'RE A
RESTAURANT THAT ONLY SERVES
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE. HE GOT
TWENTY FIVE C. SEVENTY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE ARE TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE SHOW UP I MEAN
IT'S SUCH A IT'S SUCH A-
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE- DEBT
THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN IN ORDER TO DO. A
THOROUGH CONTACT INVESTIGATION
FOR EACH CASE SO I THINK ONE OF
THE KEY TAKE HOMES IS THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT. TRUE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY
TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE
PANDEMIC WHEN IT OCCURS. AND
THAT'S A GOOD THING PART OF THE
PART OF THE WORK OF THE FUTURE-
AND WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WORKING WITH- WITH LEGISLATORS
TO TRY AND ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO STAFF TO THE
CAPACITY THAT. THAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED- DOWN THE ROAD. TO THE
QUESTION OF THE- OF THE- YOU
KNOW THE DATA. ENTER OF
TRANSMISSION- WE ARE APPLYING
PUBLIC HEALTH PRINCIPLES- AS
ENVIRONMENTAL DIRECTOR
INDICATED WORK WORK FINE WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT HOW THE DISEASE
IS TRANSMITTED TO ANY SETTING
WHERE THOSE CONDITIONS ARE IN
PLACE SO I THINK AS WE STEP
BACK WE ALSO NEED TO BE HUMBLE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO EXPECT NEXT TIME
THAT A PUREDATA RIGHT IT'S
BEGINNING. THAT THAT SEEMS TO
BE BEING ASKED FOR AT THIS
POINT IN TERMS OF POLICY WE
KNOW THERE'S A RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS IT'S TRANSMITTED
BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS OF A
CERTAIN DISTANCE RUSSIA NOT
COVERING THEIR FACES WE WOULD
ASSUME THAT. KIND OF DILIGENCE
AND GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICE
ASSUME THAT TO BE TRUE WHETHER
IT'S HAPPENING IN A CHURCH
THAT'S HAPPENING A RESTAURANT
WHERE THERE'S HAPPENING AT
SCHOOL BUT THERE'S HAPPENING AT
HOME. AND WE SEE THAT ACROSS
THE BOARD- AND SO THAT'S THAT-
YOU KNOW THE LOGIC AND THE
PRINCIPLE THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO FIRST FOR LIVE ON AS WE- ARE
ABLE TO SOMEWHAT MORE SPECIFIC
EVIDENCE- AS PRECAUTIONARY
PRINCIPLE. FOR SECTOR BY SECTOR
USING GOOD DATA THAT'S
ACCUMULATED THROUGH AN ADEQUATE-PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT CAN ACTUALLY ACQUIRE THAT
KIND OF DATA REPORTED. THANK
YOU DOCTOR MOST. OF THE SHOW WE
WILL MOVE ON I'M SURE WE'LL
REVISIT SOME OF THE STRANGE.
GUY IN THE NEXT PANEL WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL
TO EXPLORE CROSS SECTION OF
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
EXPERIENCES. DURING THE
PANDEMIC WILL HEAR PERSPECTIVES
FROM OPERATORS OF SMALL TO MID
SIZED ESTABLISHMENTS AS WELL AS
AN INDEPENDENT OWNER. WE ALSO
HAVE A RESTAURANT WITH US TODAY
DID PARTICIPATE IN THE GREAT
PLATES DELIVERED PROGRAM
DISCUSSED THEIR EXPERIENCE.
WITH THIS COMMUNITY A PROGRAM
PROMPTED BY THE PANDEMIC WILL
HEAR FIRST FROM JOHN TALENT
SHOWS. MR COACHES PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER. OF
SPECIALLY RESTAURANTS
CORPORATION S. R. C. IS A
FAMILY OWNED ENTERPRISES BEEN
IN BUSINESS FOR OVER. SIXTY
YEARS MR TELL SHOW OVERSEAS
OPERATIONS SEVERAL RESTAURANTS
INCLUDING. NINE THROUGHOUT THE
SOUTHERN. CALIFORNIA REGION
WELCOME MISTER TASHA. AFTERNOON
HI CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIRMAN AND
OTHER SENATORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
REALLY APPRECIATED. YOU KNOW SO
FAR THIS IS BEEN NOT REALLY.
INTERESTING AND EDUCATIONAL FOR
ME. ALWAYS SOMETHING MORE TO
LEARN SO THANK YOU. HI I'M A
SECOND GENERATION RESTAURATEUR
WERE OUR FIRST RESTAURANT
OPENED IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
MY DAD. CALLED THE REEF
RESTAURANT. IT WAS THERE EVEN
BEFORE THE QUEEN MARY OPENED
UP. AND OVER TIME. WE EXPANDED
TO OTHER RESTAURANTS THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
CASTAWAY. BURBANK AND- THE
PROBLEM BIRD ALLEY ACTS. WE
DEVELOP PORTS OF CALL VILLAGE
BACK IN THE DAY. OR CHILL
RESTAURANT TO NAME A FEW OF OUR
OUR LOCATION SO. AS A FAMILY
BUSINESS ALL OF OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS GREW UP IN THE
BUSINESS. I STARTED AS A- AS A
DISHWASHER AND- AND- YOU KNOW
IT WORKED OUR WAY UP AND- THE
RESTAURANT BUSINESS HAS BEEN
PART OF OUR FAMILY. YOU KNOW
FROM OVER SIXTY YEARS SO. YOU
KNOW THIS IS BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE WE ARE FACED.
AND YOU KNOW BEING A FAMILY.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO LAY OFF AS
MANY PEOPLE FOR LOW I SHOULD
SAY AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE DO IT.
NOW IT WAS IT WAS EMOTIONAL
TIME AND I THINK FOR ALL THE
OTHER OPERATORS ON THIS CALL IS
GOING TO SAY. YOU KNOW THOSE
WERE TIMES WERE. YEAH NOBODY
KNEW IF WE WERE GONNA MAKE IT
THROUGH WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
NEXT WE HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOKING TO US AS THE LEADERS
IS. TO GIVE PEOPLE ANSWERS. SO
LIKE RESTAURATEURS- WE FIGURED
IT OUT. AND WE WERE QUICKLY TO
PREVENT TO- WHAT WAS NEEDED. TO
SURVIVE. A SCHOOL MORE BACK AS
WE HAVE EACH OKAY. WERE LITTLE
YOU B. ALMOST FIFTY PER OF OUR-
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WAS DRIVEN.
SELLS RESTAURANT LIKE A HOTEL
BUT WITHOUT THE HOTEL ROOMS. A
SO A LARGE PART OF MY BUSINESS
TODAY IT STILL IS NOT OPEN AND%
OPERATING BECAUSE THE EVENT
BUSINESS BEING RESTRICTED. I
SWEAR THAT'S KIND OF A LADDER
FOR US- BUT WE HAVE RESTAURANTS
IN FLORIDA WE HAVE SIX
RESTAURANTS IN FLORIDA SO. ONE
IN NEW YORK STATE AND- TO AN
OHIO SO WE HAD A CHANCE TO. YOU
KNOW EXPERIENCES IN MANY OTHER
STATES TO SEE HOW THINGS WRE
HAPPENING THERE VERSUS
HAPPENING YOUR CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE THE ONLY COUNTY WE HAVE
ORANGE COUNTY SO WE GOT A
CHANCE. TO WORK WITH IN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. BUT FOR US
IT STARTED OUT WITH US.
FOLLOWING 92% OF OUR STAFF. AND
YOU KNOW THAT WAS REALLY
DIFFICULT AS YOU PROBABLY
REMEMBER BACK IN BUT THAT TIME
IT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT FOR.
FOR EMPLOYEES TO GET
UNEMPLOYMENT. YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A RUSH FOR THAT. MY FAMILY
AND I CREATED A SIGNED AND FOR
ABOUT THREE WEEKS WE'RE
ACTUALLY FINDING OUR EMPLOYEES
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
FURLOUGHED. ACIDITY STILL COULD
HELP PAY FOR ESSENTIALS.
BECAUSE IT WAS- IT WAS
EMOTIONAL TIME FOR THEM AND
VERY DIFFICULT- BECAUSE OUR
RESTAURANTS DIDN'T GET ANY
NOTICE WE HAD QUITE A BIT OF
FOOD. WE HAVE DONE THAT YEAH
TEN TWENTY THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WORTH OF FOOD IN OUR
RESTAURANTS AND LOTS OF PAPER
TOWELS LOTS OF TOILET PAPER.
AND SO WE SWITCHED AND WE
ACTUALLY DID CARE PACKAGES FOR
OUR TEAM MEMBERS AND THAT WENT
ON FOR SIX MONTHS. YOU KNOW YOU
AS YOU RECALL IT WAS A CRAZY
TIME PEOPLE CAN GET IT BUT
INTERESTING ENOUGH THE
SUPPLIERS IN THE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS AT AN OVERSUPPLY. OF
THESE PRODUCTS AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE OUR.
OUR EMPLOYEES FOR THAT. IT'S A
RESTAURANT HAD A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES. IN AFTER CLOSE. TO
TWO. TRAIN TO GO. WE DROP DOWN
TO THE SEVEN TO TEN EMPLOYEES.
FOR REST. BECAUSE THE MY TO DO
TO GO DIDN'T REQUIRES PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE WEREN'T SERVING YES.
SO WE TRY TO TRANSITION THESE
TWENTY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
RESTAURANTS. DID YOU GO AND FOR
US IT WASN'T A VERY GOOD
TRANSITION WE'RE VERY
EXPERIENCE WE OUT. EACH YEAR
FULL ICONIC LOCATIONS WITH USE
AND- YOU KNOW FOOD IS. PART OF
THAT EXPERIENCE BUT THE
LOCATION WAS A HUGE PART SO FOR
US TO GO ACTUALLY COST US MORE
MONEY. AS THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS OF EXPERIMENTING WITH TO
GO WE WERE ACTUALLY. LOSING
MORE MONEY THAN WE ARE ACTUALLY
GAINING. BY THE CLOSE. YEAH
THAT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE A LOT EMPLOYEES WERE
HOPING TO SEE THAT THAT WAS
KIND OF RAMP. UP AND BE
SUCCESSFUL AND FOR US. WE HAVE
A- REALLY LARGE OUTDOOR PATIO
SPACE WE HAVE A LARGE PARKING
AREAS. AND SO ONCE WE WERE
ALLOWED TO INVITE GUESTS BACK
TO OUR SITES. I WOULD SAY WE
WERE THE POSTER CHILD FOR. A
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY FOR A
RESTAURANT. YOU KNOW YES THEY
CAN BE SPREAD OUT. THEY REALLY
ENJOY A SHOWING UP TO THE
LOCATIONS AND FEELING SAFE. AND
YOU KNOW WE CREATED A LOT OF
SPACE AND SO WE FOUND
OURSELVES. IN MANY OF OUR
RESTAURANTS THAT WERE OPEN
DOING AS MUCH BUSINESS WE ARE
THIS WE WOULD BE DOING WHAT WE
ARE DOING IT FAST. IT'S THAT
MUCH DEMAND RIGHT NOW
UNFORTUNATELY I ADDS FIVE
RESTAURANTS ARE CLOSED IT
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE THIS TYPE OF
SETTING I KNOW MANY
RESTAURATEURS. ON THIS CALL YOU
DON'T HAVE THOSE SETTINGS IF
YOU COULD EXPAND LIKE WE COULD.
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE SO WE'RE
KIND OF- YOU KNOW YEAH SHE STIR
FAMINE IN OUR BUSINESS RIGHT
NOW WITH OUR LOCATIONS-
MEETINGS THAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO
WHILE WE WERE OPERATING. YOU
KNOW OU LOOK FOR THE GOOD IS
THAT WE WERE SUPPLYING MEALS TO
THE ORANGE COUNTY FIRE IN
ORANGE COUNTY POLICE LA COUNTY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LARGE
KITCHENS YOUKNOW JUST DIDN'T
FEEL RIGHT TO NOT DO ANYTHING
SO WE REACHED OUT TO SEE WHAT
WE COULD DO. AND YOU KNOW THAT
WORKS OUT REALLY WELL FOR NOW
WE'RE SUPPLYING YOU KNOW COUPLE
MEALS A DAY FOR A WHILE AND THE
TEAM MEMBERS YOU KNOW WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
PART OF SOMETHING- WE ALSO
DONATED EXTRA MEALS TO SOME
HOTELS. HOSPITALS I THE AREA.
YEAH YOU KNOW YOU JUST GAVE OUR
TEAM MEMBER SOMETHING THAT THEY
FELT LIKE THEY WERE
CONTRIBUTING WELL YOU KNOW THE
EARLY DAYS. EVERYBODY WAS JUST
SHUT DOWN. YOU KNOW I THINK ONE
OF THE- THAT ALL OF US FACED IS
THAT WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AND
MONEY. FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
NEW PLANE STILL GONNA BE WE
SPEND MONEY ON. PROTECTIONS IN
DIVIDERS- ALL KINDS OF THINGS
TO CREATE AREAS SAFE FOR OUR
GAS. AND THEN WE THOUGHT WE
WERE DOING WELL WITH THAT AND
THEN. YOU KNOW THAT. LIKE
ANYTHING ELSE TO FIND OUT MORE
WHAT WORKS WHAT DOESN'T WORK
AND YOU FIND OUT THAT SOME OF
THOSE PROTECTIONS. WERE A WASTE
OF MONEY- WE GOT CLOSED DOWN
OUTDOORS YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE IT
GOT. A SHOT AT THE GUY- YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND. THAT TO
DATE ABOUT THAT NOT LIKE TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
LATER MY ROOM REMARKS STATING
IT WAS IT WAS VERY CHALLENGING
TO GET TO WORK. YOU KNOW
OUTDOOR DINING WASN'T GONNA
WORK. FOR US TODAY. WE ARE
PLANNING ON. OPENING A THREE OF
OUR FIVE RESTAURANTS HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ONCE JUNE
FIFTEEN HEADS WHEN WE HAVE LESS
RESTRICTIONS ON OFFENSE. WE
REALLY TRIED THAT BY JAPAN'S.
AND GUESTS ARE STILL LITTLE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO GATHER TOGETHER.
AND TO YOU KNOW A BIG EVENTS
LIKE WE HAVE YOU KNOW TWO
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED GASKET
SET IN OUR BALL ROOMS. NOW ARE
GOING TO BE A WAYS DOWN THE
ROAD WE DON'T ANTICIPATE EVEN
THROUGH THE HOLIDAYS. AND THAT
THE EVENT BUSINESS IS GOING TO
BE. THAT STRONG JUST BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A HESITATION. AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF CORPORATE
CLIENTS THAT YOU KNOW CORPORATE
CORPORATIONS ARE READY. TO STEP
UP AND- AND- AND- SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE ON. RAMP UP ON THE
EVENT ISN'T ANYBODY IN THE
CATERING BUSINESS RENTALS THAT
KIND OF STUFF IT'S GONNA BE.
IT'S GONNA BE A WHILE. YEAH
AND- IT YOU KNOW TODAY WE'RE
FACED WITH HUGE SUPPLY ISSUES
WE TALK ABOUT LABOR. BUT ON THE
SUPPLY SIDE. YEAH BECAUSE THE
LABOR CAN'T GET YOU KNOW WITH
TRACKING. AND AND PRODUCTION
SIDE WE'RE SEEING A SUPPLY
ISSUE OUT THERE. IN SOME CASES
YOU KNOW IT'S TOO MUCH OF A
GOOD THING. AND I'M A LITTLE
AFRAID THAT YOU KNOW WITH ALL
THE MONEY COMING INTO EMPLOYS.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD SAY IT'S
KEEPING HIM FROM WORKING. IN A
LOT OF MONEY IS FINALLY BACK TO
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. AND
IT'S SOMEWHAT ARTIFICIAL IN
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S FLOWING
TODAY. YEAH PLEASE OUT OF WORK
AND YOU HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO DO
SO THEY'RE EATING IN
RESTAURANTS AND SO THAT'S
FANTASTIC. BUT THAT'S KIND OF
THE SHORT ROUTE SHORT RUN
SOLUTION FOR US YEAH WE STILL
THINK WHEN THAT'S DRIES UP IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY CHALLENGING.
WHAT ONE LAST THING I'D LIKE TO
SAY IS THAT. YOU KNOW AS FAR AS
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT'S CONCERN.
I THINK IT'S REALLY KIND OF
IRONIC ABOUT WHAT WHAT HAPPENED
I WOULD SAY GOING IN THE
PANDEMIC BEFORE. THAT R. AS
RESTAURATEURS OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
WELL IT WAS ONE THAT ALL
INDUSTRIES. TOP OF MINE EVERY
DAY WAS CAST SIXTY AN EMPLOYEE
SAFETY. AND WE FELT WE HAD A
VERY UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT IF
THERE WAS A MESSAGE TO PROTECT
YES. OF COURSE THERE'S ALWAYS
BAD ACTORS OUT THERE BUT I
WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW 99%
RESTAURANTS WANTED TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. THAT WE SHOULDN'T
YOU KNOW WOULD BE THE ONES TO
BE CALLED UPON TO DO THE RIGHT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY. I'M YOU KNOW
AND IN THIS KIND OF TIES BACK
TO SOME OF THE STUFF THE
PROTECTIONS WHEN YOU HAVE
GROCERY STORES BEING REMAIN
OPEN AND OTHER PLACES. NOT
BEING ASKED TO BE CLOSED I
THINK THERE WAS A REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESTAURANTS.
TODAY THIS DAY I THINK THERE'S
A PROBLEM WHETHER PERCEIVED
MAYBE NOT TO BE A SAFE PLACE TO
GO TO BECAUSE- EVERYBODY WAS
BACKED AGAINST THE WALL TO SAY
WELL WHY ARE YOU CLOSING OR
CLOSING ON BECAUSE IT'S NOT
SAFE. WHEN WE REALLY. MAYBE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
BUT PRECAUTIONARY WISE WE HAD
TO DO THAT AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT. BUT I THINK THERE IS FOR
RESTAURANTS TODAY PART OF OUR
CHALLENGE IS OUR MESSAGING BACK
TO OUR GAS HOW DO WE BE
PERCEIVED AGAIN AS A SAFE
PLACE. THAT WE DO HAVE THEIR-
BEST INTEREST IN MIND. AND
THAT- AND BILL BACK THAT
RELATIONSHIP THAT WAS VERY
STRONG WITH THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER. BECAUSE WE REALLY DO
RELY ON THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR SHAYS WHO. WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT HOUSE TONIGHT.
WITH AN EYE ON TIME I'D I'D
ASK. THAT EACH OF THE SECOND
PANELIST BAM. THE TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE- EXPEDITE YOUR REMARKS
THAT WE DON'T RUN OUT OF TIME.
AVONEX WILL TURN TO JENNIFER
PUSHER- WITH HODGMAN
HOSPITALITY GROUP. THE
HOSPITALITY HOTEL GIVES A
FAMILYOWNED RESTAURANT GROUP
OPERATES IS NINETEEN FIFTY ONE.
AND AS A IN HOUSE COUNSEL AND
IS PUSHING MANAGES THEIR DATED
A HUMAN RESOURCES OPERATIONS-
AND WE LOOK FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVES. GOOD AFTERNOON.
VICE CHAIRMEN SENATORS ASSEMBLY
PERSONS AND STAFF THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
OUR EXPERIENCE OUR SYSTEM TAKES
AWAY AND WHAT NEED REALLY NEED
I'M FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW IN ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD
SUCCESSFULLY SELL A LITTLE BAD
ABOUT. HOSPITALITY WE ARE FORTY
THREE LOCATIONS FORTY ONE OF
THEM ARE IN CALIFORNIA WE- ARE
EXPERIENCING A BAD ERRORS ON IT
AS WELL AS YEAH. BEAR WITH A
CALIFORNIA WE'RE WITHIN THREE
YEARS- AND A TOTAL OF NINE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT BECAUSE WE'RE
ALSO IN LONG BEACH I'M
PARTICULAR NOTE. ATLASSIAN
JEALOUS COUNTY AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND I'M ECSTATIC LONG
BEACH COUNTY WE HAVE THE MOST
PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE WITH THE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- NOW ALL I
HAVE BUT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
JUST. HAVE THREE QUICK TALKING
PLAIN AREAS THAT I THINK WILL
NEED THE MOST HELP TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AS A RESTAURANT
GOING FORWARD AND THEN I'D LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT THE REASONS WHY.
I'M FIRST IT JUST REQUIREMENTS
IN RESTAURANTS THERE'S BEEN SO
MUCH TALK ABOUT NO MORE MASS.
I'M WHICH IS HELPFUL TO SOME
GAS FOR US WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY
INCREASE IN OCCUPANCY- SINCE WE
MOVED INTO THE RED CHAIR
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR BILLS ARE
STATIONARY AND EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE HUGE TALL PARTITION. ARE
WE CAN'T EVEN GET. PERCENT ARE.
IN OUR RESTAURANTS BECAUSE THE
DISTANCE TEAM- LOCKED INTO THIS
COUNTY PARTICULARLY CAN'T MOVE
OUR TABLES. WE'RE REALLY NOT
ABLE TO SEE MANY PEOPLE SO
WHILE THE MASS WELL IT'S
EXCITING TO SLAM IT IT'S NOT
GOING TO HELP DRIVE BUSINESS-
AND ALLOW US TO HIRE BACK WHERE
WORKERS- SECONDLY IT'S WITH THE
WORKERS WORKERS LEFT CALIFORNIA
LAST THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. I
THINK. THE STRUTS BROKE AGAIN I
MEAN. WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS
I FIRST HAD TO HELP FURLOUGH
OVER TWO THOUSAND. BECAUSE WHEN
YOU SHUT CAME INTO PLAY NOT
ONE. BUT TWO TIMES AND THEY
WERE EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY YOU
HAVE TO SEND EVERYONE HOME. AT
LOOKING BACK AT THE WHOLE
EXPERIENCE POSSIBLY WE COULD.
FOR THE LAST YOU PAUL IF YEAH
ACTIVE DATE WASN'T IMMEDIATELY.
I'M AND IT WENT ON FOR SO LONG-
IN TERMS OF THE CLOSURE ARE I'M
DINING SCENE AND THEN THE
CLOSURE AND OUTDOOR DINING. AND
THEN FINALLY WHAT THE BRAND
STANDS BECAUSE ORIGINALLY I
THINK THERE WAS LEGISLATION.
WELL RESTAURANT GROUPS WITH
LANDLORDS THAT WERE BEING
UNREASONABLE AND RENEGOTIATING
RENTS AND THEN THAT WAS TAKEN
OFF THE TABLE GOING FORWARD YOU
KNOW A LOT OF IT WAS JUST RIGHT
TO FARM IT AND EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE A LARGE RESTAURANT GROUP
OUR OVERHEAD IS VERY HIGH. IN
TERMS OF ALL OF THAT YOU KNOW
GREAT WALLS WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR INCREASED
MINIMUM WAGE- BUT IT'S ALSO
INCREASED COSTS. AND WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO FIND A WAY
FORWARD- AND ALSO I THINK WHEN
YOU GET BACK TO WORKERS THE
IMMIGRATION REFORM REALLY HELP
US IN THAT AREA AS WELL. I'M I
JUST WANT TO MAKE BAD THREE
POINT TO KIND OF DRIVE THOSE
THREE SOLUTIONS I'M OFFERING.
OUR SUGGESTIONS. THAT MADE
SEVENTY AREAS SUCH. FOR US
DURING THE PAST. I PERSONALLY
HAVE SEEN I'M EIGHTY NINE OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEEDED MORE OF A
CONSISTENT WALL. I'M FINE YEAH
I PROVIDED A LOT OF GUIDANCE
BUT THEN WHEN WE HAD A HEALTH
DEPARTMENT LIKE LAST ANGELES
COUNTY THAT MULTIPLE DAYS LATER
WITH BRO I'M- ALAS CENTRALIZE
MORE RESTRICTIVE APPROACH. AND
WE ALREADY STARTED MODELING
OURSELVES AFTER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN FRIDAY AT
SIX PM LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUT
BRING OUT THEIR REGULATIONS
RIGHT. YEAH BEIJING ALL ACTIVE
IMMEDIATELY FOR ALL OF YOUR
SERVERS I MEAN THERE WERE NO
FACE SHIELDS WE LITERALLY HAD
TO DRIVE TRAFFIC CALIFORNIA TO
GET SPACE YELLED BY THE NEXT
MORNING- AND AGAIN ALSO THE
TACTIC PARTITIONS WE SPENT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS I'M PAST THAT
PARTITIONS THAT. WE WERE NEVER
ABLE TO USE AND THEN IT'S A
NICE. PERCEPTION FOR SAFETY. I
BUT LACK OF. A CONSISTENT RULES-
AND THEN THE LACK OF EDUCATION
BEHIND THOSE WALLS AGAIN WE
HAVE MANY RESTAURANTS IN LA
COUNTY SO THAT MOST OF MY
EXPERIENCE. BUT IT WASN'T
NECESSARILY EDUCATION BASE
THERE WERE A LOT OF OCCASIONS
WHERE WE WERE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY COULD TO FOLLOW ALL THE
RULES AND WE WOULD BE. FINE NO
WARNING A FINE AND IT JUST FELT
LIKE WE WERE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE COULD FOR OUR
WORKERS AND IT OUT SOMEWHAT AND
IF YOU NEED AN APPROACH ONE IN
EVERY OTHER ASPECT OF YOUR
COMPLIANCE. I'M AND THAT ALSO
GOES LAG AND THEY TRAINED ME
MESSAGE EVERYTHING WAS
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY. AND
THERE WAS WASTED FOOD IF THERE
WAS YOU KNOW I WAS TRYING TO
COMPLY WITH THE CHILD LEARN AND
OTHERWISE AT THE SAME TIME
PROVIDING EMPLOYEES WITH
SUFFICIENT NOTICE WHEN WE HAD
TO CLOSE. TWENTY LOCATIONS-
WITHIN A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
PERIOD MORE THAN ONCE- AND THEN
AGAIN THE NOTE THE NOTE. WELL
RANTS KERAMAT OURS FOR
LANDLORDS I UNDERSTAND THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN LENDERS. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME- THAT THAT GOES A
LOT OF OUR MONEY THAT WE
WEREN'T BRINGING MEN AND I KNOW
THERE WAS SOME ASSISTANCE FROM
THE GOVERNMENT WHICH IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND UTILIZED IN
BRINGING BACK OUR WORKERS- BUT
IT IS STILL AN UNCERTAIN
FUTURE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
REOPENING- AND I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT. HI I MEAN I HAD THE
ABILITY TO JUST IMMEDIATELY GO
OUTSIDE IN THE FUTURE LIKE SAN
DIEGO DID WOULD BE AMAZING
ESPECIALLY IN LA COUNTY.
BECAUSE I LANDLORDS FORCED US
TO RENEGOTIATE OUR LEASE SAYS
TO GET THAT EXTRA SPACE TO PAY
MORE FOR THAT SPACE IN THE
PARKING LOT. AND IT WOULD TAKE
WEEKS TO RENEGOTIATE IT AT
TIMES. I'M SO WHAT HELPED IF
THEY COULD HAVE DONE AND
IMMEDIATELY WENT OUT OR DINING
WAS OPEN- AND ALSO LIKE IN SOME
OF OUR LOCATIONS WE TOOK THE
REAL FIVE OR THE WINDOWS
LOCKED. AND WE HAD A LOT OF
SPECULATION AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE LA COUNTY LOCATIONS THAT WE
GOT I MEDIATE WE SAT DOWN AT
BECAUSE IT WAS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU WANTED
THE OPEN AIR SPACE- BUT IT
TURNED OUT- OUR CREATIVE.
SOLUTION WHAT THE NEXT STEP.
THANK YOU MUCH FOR TIME AND
YOUR ENERGY. IT WAS- THEY FELT
LIKE. ME WE ALL HAVE LEARNED A
LOT FROM THIS PAST YEAR AND I
HOPE THAT IN THE FUTURE ARE ARE
WE HAVE A BETTER ATHLETES
FORWARD ASK YOUR DISCOUNT AND
MAKE AND ANY FUTURE ONE. AND SO
WE CAN BE MORE SUCCESSFUL ASK
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES AND- YOU'RE
PROVIDING SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR MAKING
YOURSELF WELL AND FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE- WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS HAVE THE PILLARS-%
THIRD PRESENTER WILL BE LOWER
IN THE GROUP. WHO WITH HER
HUSBAND PAUL ARE THE
PROPRIETORS OF ROOF DESTROYED
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- AND SHE
MANAGES THE SERVICE THE
MARKETING AND EVERYTHING ELSE
RELATED TO THE FRONT OF THE
HOUSE. IN A SMALL RESTAURANTS
WHO WILL COMMISSION A GROUP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME- SENATOR NEWMAN THANK
YOU FOR SETTING UP THIS PANEL
AND FOR ALL OF THE SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY PERSON THAT ARE ON
THIS THANK YOU. SO A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT ME BECAUSE I THINK-
I'M IN A KIND OF A UNIQUE
POSITION SO MY HUSBAND AND I
OPENED THIS RESTAURANT FIVE
YEARS AGO- WHERE THE PARENTS OF
THREE. GIRLS AGES THIRTEEN
TWELVE AND TEN. BUT IN ADDITION
TO OWNING A RESTAURANT IWAS
ALSO A PART TIME EMPLOYEE AT A
HOTEL IN SAN FRANCISCO IN THEIR
BANQUET DEPARTMENT I'D BEEN
THERE FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS. AND
SHE GETS A HIGH END
RESTAURANTS- I PROBABLY HAVE
SERVED I SERVE THE GOVERNOR
SEVERAL TIMES US SENATORS
DIGNITARIES. AND SO I DID THAT
JOB I LOVED IT BUT ALSO
PROVIDED HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
MY FAMILY. IT ALSO PROVIDED A
THIRD OF OUR FAMILY'S INCOME-
AND MY PERSPECTIVE ON THE WHOLE
BIT SITUATION WAS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN MANY OF MY OTHER
RESTAURANT. OWNER ASSOCIATES IN
THIS AREA BECAUSE I WAS GETTING
BRIEFED EVERY TIME I WENT INTO
WORK FIRE GENERAL MANAGER OF
WHAT SHE WAS HEARING FROM THEIR
CORPORATE OFFICE- I WAS WORKING
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHEN NANCY
PELOSI FAMOUSLY CAME TO CHINA
TOWN. I TOLD EVERYONE TO COME
VISIT. AND THEN ONE DAY LATER
MAYOR BREED SHUT THE CITY.
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
REALMS AGAINST A SMALL FRENCH
BISTRO MY HUSBAND IS AN
IMMIGRANT FROM FRANCE HE'S BEEN
HERE FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS.
FRENCH FOOD IS NOT TAKE OUT
FOOD. WHERE A HIGHER END
RESTAURANT OUR AVERAGE TICKET
PRICES AROUND SEVENTY DOLLARS A
PERSON. WE'RE OPEN FOR DINNER
ONLY FIVE DAYS A WEEK WE'RE
CLOSED ON SUNDAYS AND MONDAYS.
AND OUR PROFIT MARGIN IS ABOUT
FIVE PERCENT. SO FOR EVERY
HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT WE BRING
IN. FIVE DOLLARS OF PROFIT AND
THAT PROFIT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
INITIAL LOAN THAT WE TOOK OUT
TO BUY THE RESTAURANTS. SO
EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE MAKE AS
PROFIT. IS GOING BACK INTO THE
RESTAURANT TO PAY OFF OUR LOAN.
AND HOPEFULLY CREATE A SAVINGS
ACCOUNT FOR US. SO WHEN WE GOT
THE NOTICE ON A SUNDAY. THAT
NEXT WEEK OUR RESTAURANT WAS
GOING TO GET SHOT DOWN. WE HAD
A 100% OF IT I HAD TO CREATE A
NEW BUSINESS PLAN IN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS I HAD TO CREATE A
NEW BUSINESS MODEL WE DIDN'T
HAVE GORD ASH CONTRACTS. I
DIDN'T HAVE A- ONLINE SET UP OR
TAKE AWAY WE DIDN'T HAVE AN
ONLINE MENU. I HAVE A FRENCH
CHEF HUSBAND WHO IS VERY MUCH A
LOGICAL IT IS VERY INTENSE VERY
FOCUSED MASTER WHAT HE DOES AND
HE HAD TO CREATE ITS MENU
MODIFY HIS MENU. FOR WHAT COULD
BE ENJOYED AT HOME OUT OF A TO
GO BOX. WE LET SOME OF OUR
STAFF GO- AND WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE A SMALL
STAFF WE ONLY HAVE EIGHTEEN
EMPLOYEES. WE HAD SEVERAL THAT
DID NOT WANT TO WORK. THEY
WANTED TO STAY HOME THEY
VOLUNTEERED TO STAY HOME. AND
WE KEPT THE REST OF EVERYONE
WORKING. WE WERE VERY BLESSED
WHERE IN THE LAFAYETTE
COMMUNITY AND- I MAINTAIN AN
EMAIL LIST OF OVER FOUR
THOUSAND OF OUR GUESTS. AND I'M
VERY ACTIVE WITH THEM AND I
SENT OUT EMAILS EVERY WEEK. AND
WE SENT OUT AN EMAIL AND WE
SAID WE'RE MAKING LEMONADE OUT
OF LEMONS. AND HERE'S OUR TODO
MENU AND THE LAFAYETTE
COMMUNITY STEPPED UP. THE CITY
OF LAFAYETTE STEPPED UP. THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WAS
IMMENSELY HELPFUL. AND THEN WE
GET INTO OUR COUNTY. AND EVEN
IN OUR STATE. THE GUIDANCE WAS
HORRIBLE COMMUNICATION WAS
HORRIBLE. A COUPLE OF OUR
COUNTY MEMBERS WOULD JOKE ON
THEIR PERSONAL SOCIAL MEDIA
PAGES ABOUT HAVING TO SHOP ON
AMAZON. WHILE THE BUSINESSES
AROUND THEM IN THEIR COUNTY
WERE SHUTTING DOWN- WE HAD
OTHER ONES THAT WOULD ANNOUNCE
A PURSE THE FUTURE OPENING. ON
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA PAGES NOT IN
AN OFFICIAL CAPACITY. AND THEN
WE WOULDN'T GET ANY GUIDANCE
FROM THE COUNTY UNTIL TWENTY
FOUR HOURS BEFORE OR SAME DAY.
SO HOW DO YOU RUN A BUSINESS
HOW DO YOU MANAGE EMPLOYEES HOW
DO YOU MANAGE GUESTS WHEN YOU
DON'T KNOW FROM DAY TO DAY OR
WEEK TO WEEK WHAT THAT BUSINESS
LOOKS LIKE. AND I UNDERSTAND IT
WAS AN EVER CHANGING PICTURE I
EMPATHIZE WITH THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR HEALTH
INSPECTOR AND WHAT COUNTY
HEALTH AS LITTLE AS WE DEAL
WITH THEM WHICH IS ALWAYS A
GOOD THING WHEN YOU'RE A
RESTAURANT YOU GET YOUR
INSPECTIONS AND EVERYONE SMILES
AND THINGS GO GOOD AND THAT'S
IT AND THAT'S ALL IT SHOULD BE
BECAUSE- OUR MAIN PRIORITY IS
KEEPING EVERYONE HEALTHY. WHITE
HEALTHY AND SAFE. SO WHEN WE
WERE OPEN FOR OUTDOOR AND I'M
SITTING RIGHT NOW IN OUR PATIO
WAS VERY BLESSED WE HAVE A HUGE
OUTDOOR PATIO WE HAVE A VERY
SMALL RESTAURANT INSIDE- BUT WE
WERE ALLOWED TO OPEN FOR
OUTDOOR DINING AND THEN ALL OF
A SUDDEN IT SHUT DOWN AND IT'S
TAKEN AWAY. AND AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL WE ASKED THEM WHY WHY WHY
WE PRESENTED WITH- RESEARCH
THAT WAS SHOWING OTHER STUDIES
IN OTHER COUNTRIES THAT WERE
DONE THAT WERE SHOWING THAT IT
WASN'T GETTING SPREAD IN
OUTDOOR DINING. AND WE WERE
JUST TOLD THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH IT CAN YOU PROVIDE
US DATA YOU'RE SHUTTING OUR
BUSINESS DOWN YOU'RE LETTING
PEOPLE SHOP AT COSTCO YOU'RE
DOING ALL THESE THINGS. AND SO
TO REACH BACK TO THAT POINT OF
WHERE IS THIS DATA. WE COULDN'T
GET THE ATA AND AS BUSINESS
OWNERS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
EVERYONE STRUGGLING WITH TRYING
TO MAKE SENSE OF ALL OF THIS.
BUT POLICIES SEEM TO JUST BE
MADE ON A WHIM AND THEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT POLITICAL OFFICIALS
WHO AREN'T FOLLOWING THE
POLICIES AND THE GUIDANCE THAT
THEY'RE PUTTING INTO PLACE.
THAT WE CAN GET SHUT DOWN FOR
AND FIND THAT WE'RE GETTING
THREATENED TO LOSE OUR BUSINESS
TO GET FINED IF AND WHEN THESE
THINGS HAPPEN. AND THEN WE'RE
SEEING LEADING OFFICIALS NOT
FOLLOWING THE SAME GUIDELINES.
YOU KNOW AT THE SAME TIME OUR
THREE KIDS WERE OUT OF SCHOOL
SO WE HAD TO SWITCH TO ONLINE
LEARNING. THE BLAST AND THAT MY
PARENTS ARE HERE. AND THEY
COULD TAKE OVER MY CHILD CARE
FOR ME. BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO COME BACK. AND OUR
ISSUE WITH COMING BACK AS
EMPLOYEES WE HAVE THREE
POSITIONS THAT ARE OPEN.
THEY'VE BEEN OPEN FOR A COUPLE
MONTHS NOW. AND IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS WE'VE HAD TWO PEOPLE
TURNED DOWN OFFERS BECAUSE PART
ISN'T RUNNING. AGAIN WE'RE A
DINNER ONLY RESTAURANT WE HAVE
COOKS THAT WORKED UNTIL TEN OR
ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT. AND WE
HAVE EMPLOYEES THEY'RE NOT
LIVING IN LAFAYETTE THEY DON'T
LIVE IN A WIND UP THEY DON'T
LIVE ALONG THE CREEK THEY LIVE
IN OAKLAND AND BERKELEY IN
PITTSBURG AND BAY POINT. A LOT
OF THEM RELY ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND THERE'S NO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER SITUATION THAT WE
HAVE. IS IN JANUARY WE. HAD A
MINIMUM WAGE HIKE WAIT A MINUTE.
AND LET ME TELL YOU MY MINIMUM
WAGE EMPLOYEE IS MY HIGHEST
HOURLY PAID EMPLOYEES THAT'S MY
TIPPED EMPLOYEE. WELL I CAN'T
FIND A COOK. BECAUSE ALREADY ON
THAT 45% LABOR COST BECAUSE
FEES KEEP GOING UP UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES GO UP AND WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN TWO YEARS WHEN THE
STATE REALIZES THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY MORE UNEMPLOYMENT MONEY
JUST LIKE THE PREVIOUS TIME
WHEN THEY RAN OUT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT MONEY THEY'RE
GONNA COME ASKING ME FOR MONEY.
I WROTE A FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR CHECK WHEN WE FIRST
OPENED THE RESTAURANT BECAUSE
THE STATE BASICALLY FIND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE RUNNING OUT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT FINDS. SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD AND I'M LOOKING
AHEAD TO THAT. SO THAT MINIMUM
WAGE HIKE WHICH COULD HAVE NOT
BEEN PUT INTO PLACE. IT HAD ALL
OF THE REASONS WHY IT SHOULDN'T
BE I KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION HEAVILY
ADVOCATED FOR IT NOT TO YOU. IT
DIDN'T GET PUT IN PLACE. SO NOW
MY PAYROLL HAS INCREASED BY 3%
BECAUSE AGAIN MY HIGHEST PAID
HOURLY EMPLOYEES JUST GOT A
RAISE BUT THE GOVERNMENT FORCED
ME TO GIVE THEM. AND THAT'S
LESS LABOR DOLLARS THAT I CAN
PAY MY COOKS WHO LEFT THE STATE
WHO WENT TO OTHER INDUSTRIES.
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO MY HANDS
ARE TIED. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND CREATIVE WAYS- WE TRY AND
OFFER WORK LIFE BALANCE ONLY
BEING OPEN FIVE DAYS A WEEK
PEOPLE SAY WILL OPEN FOR SUNDAY
BRUNCH. I DESERVE A LIFE TOO
YOU KNOW WE WOULD GET THESE
REGULATIONS ON A FRIDAY THE
GOVERNOR WOULD ANNOUNCE HERE'S
THIS WONDERFUL PROGRAM TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT. SEED SENIORS
WILL HOST RESTAURANTS GET MONEY
THESE ARE ALL THESE PROGRAMS
HERE'S THE NUMBER TO CALL. SO
WHAT I'D CALL THE NUMBER. AND I
WAS TOLD WE DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT IT THE
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WORK ON
WEEKENDS CALL BACK NEXT FRIDAY
MAYBE WE'LL HAVE SOME
INFORMATION FOR YOU. SO
PROGRAMS WERE BEING OFFERED WE
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF SOME WE WERE
GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF THE EFFORT.
BUT YOU'RE ANNOUNCING PROGRAMS
WITHOUT THEM BEING DEVELOPED.
AND IT JUST FELTLIKE EVERY DAY
THERE WAS A NEW REGULATION A
NEW DECISION AND IT JUST GOT
REALLY OVERWHELMING WE BAGS FOR
CLARITY FROM OUR COUNTY I
STEPPED ON SO MANY SPAM CALLS
BAKING AND BAKING MORE THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS NOTICE PLEASE.
AND THAT NEVER HAPPENED. SO I'M
HOPEFUL WE DO HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
PATIO RIGHT NOW WE'RE VERY
BLESSED WE'RE BUSIER THAN EVER
WE DID KEEP MOST OF OUR STAFF
SO WE'RE NOT TOO SHORT STAFFED-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M A
LITTLE HESITANT BECAUSE WE DO
NEED THOSE STAFF. AND WE DO
NEED TO GET THEM WORKING. SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO SPEAK
AND- WHAT THAT ALL ALL LANDS
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND IF IT'S ANY
CONSOLATION I'D MUCH RATHER BE
ON YOUR PATIO. THE HEARING THIS
COMMITMENT TODAY WEARING A MASK
IS SO LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST. FOR SOME PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY I
WILL HEAR FROM GREG TOOL AND-
WHO IS THE OWNER OF DYLAN SOUL
FOOD KITCHEN- AND I'M ASSUMING
MR DOING FROM YOUR YOUR- SOON
ALL IT RESTAURANT ALSO HOT
FIELD- AND- MR DOING BRINGS
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE TO US TODAY
DESCRIBED HIS EXPERIENCE WHICH
IS FITTING. IN THE STATE'S
PANDEMIC PROMPTED GREAT PLACE
TO LIVE. IN PROGRAM FOR
SENIORS. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
SERVICE AND HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU ALL FOR
INVITING ME. MY NAME IS GREG
DILLON AND I AM A SECOND
GENERATION. RESTAURANT OWNER MY
FAMILY STARTED WITH A LITTLE
HAMBURGER STAND. OR MARLIES
KING BOULEVARD IN LOS ANGELES.
AND TODAY WE CURRENTLY OPERATES
THREE. SOUL FOOD SOUTHERN STAR
RESTAURANTS. AND KNEW HOW TO
BUILD A- NATIONAL CHICKEN
RESTAURANT CALLED CHICKEN. I
THERE WE JUST TOLD UP ABOUT TWO
MONTHS BEFORE PANDEMIC HIT I
SHOULD ADD. AND THEN WE AND WE
ALSO OPERATE TWO FOOD TRUCKS
AND SO- YOU KNOW WHEN. THINGS
STARTED TO GET BACK WITH THE
PANDEMIC- THE RESTAURANTS WERE
HIT PRETTY HARD AND SOFT HE
REALLY SHARP DECLINE IN OUR
REVENUES. IN THE LOT A BIG PART
OF MY BUSINESS IS CATERING. AND
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT- THE
CATERERS AND CATERING
BUSINESSES OUT THERE BUT MY
CATERING BUSINESS. WAS WIPED
OUT 1100% AND SO- YOU KNOW WE
KNEW WE HAD TO KILL IT. BEING
IN BUSINESS FOR FIFTY YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN THROUGH A LOT. AND SO
WE KNOW HOW TO SURVIVE. AND SO-
WE STARTED LOOKING FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES AND IT SEEMS LIKE
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY. AFTER
THINGS STARTED SHUTTING DOWN I
GOT AN EMAIL FROM THE EIGHTH
COUNCIL DISTRICT HERE IN LOS
ANGELES SEEKING RESTAURANTS. TO
SERVE MEALS TO SENIORS AND
EIGHT COUNCIL DISTRICT BECAUSE
OF SENIOR MEAL CENTERS SENIOR
CENTERS ARE SHUTTING DOWN. AND
THEY WANTED TO SENIORS TO
CONTINUE GETTING THEIR MEALS.
AND SO WE WENT. FROM SERVING
SOUL FOOD DINNERS IN THE
RESTAURANT ONE DAY. TO
DELIVERING SENIOR MEALS DOOR TO
DOOR THE NEXT DAY FOR THE
EIGHTH COUNCIL DISTRICT. AND IT
WAS QUITE A QUITE A CHANGE IN
THIS IT WAS KIND OF FUN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW I HAD MY OWN ROUTE.
AND AS I WOULD GO UP TO DELIVER
THE MEALS MYSELF I KNEW
EVERYBODY I WAS DELIVERING TO.
AND SO- THAT WAS A GOOD WAY TO
CONNECT WITH MY WITH MY
CUSTOMERS. BUT THOSE FUNDS SOON%
RAN OUT AND ANNA AND I HAVE TO
MANDATE COUNCIL DISTRICT
BECAUSE THEY REPURPOSE FUNDS.
FROM ONE LITTLE PROJECT PURPOSE
TO THIS MEAL. PROGRAM AND HE
DID IT REALLY FAST. THE THOSE
PHONES RAN OUT. AND WEEKS WE
WERE ABLE TO TRANSITION AND IN
LOS ANGELES WE CALL WE CALL IT
THE MAYOR'S GREAT PLAINS SENIOR
MEAL PROGRAM- WE WERE PICKED UP
BY THE MAYOR'S GREAT PLACE THE
EMAIL PROGRAM. AND AGAIN THIS
WAS A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE MEALS
TO SENIORS IN LOS ANGELES. WHO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SEVERE FOOD
IN SECURITIES- IN SEOUL IN S.
THERE'S A BIG. PROBLEM IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES OUR RESTAURANTS
OPERATED IN IN FOOD DESERTS.
AND THERE'S TREMENDOUS FOOD. IN
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY FOR SENIOR CITIZENS.
AND SO WERE VERY HONORED TO
HAVE BEEN SELECTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM.
BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS BEEN THE
PERSON WHO LIKES TO GIVE BACK
TO MY COMMUNITY- BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT AND IT IS SOMETHING
THAT I LOVE TO DO- THE WAY THE
GREAT PLAINS PROGRAM WAS.
DESIGNED IN LOS ANGELES. IT WAS
A IT WAS A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN. THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
LOCAL RESTAURANTS IN THE YELLOW
CAB COMPANY. R. OVER TIME WE
DEVELOPED A REALLY GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP AND RELEASE
LAWLESS SYSTEM. DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WOULD. THEY DEVELOPED A
LIST OF SENIORS. CAN B. IN TURN
GAVE THAT LISTS THE YELLOW CAB
COMPANY. THEN DESIGNED A ROUTE.
OR DIFFERENT ROUTES IN THE
ASSIGNED CABS TO THE DIFFERENT
RESTAURANTS TO DELIVER THOSE
MEALS. AND SO WE HAD YOU KNOW
BETWEEN FORTY AND FIFTY
RESTAURANTS YOU KNOW EACH
RESTAURANT YOU KNOW HAVING SIX
OR SEVEN OR EIGHT CATS COMING
ON YOU KNOW TO PICK UP MEALS.
AND HE WAS REALLY GOOD OUR
RELATIONSHIP- IT WAS VERY
ORGANIZED. IT WAS VERY.
IMPACTFUL BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT WAS STILL IS LIFE SUSTAINING
IT SUSTAIN MY BUT IT'S SAVED MY
BUSINESS- WE WERE ABLE TO.
MAINTAIN OUR OUR STAFF WITHOUT
HAVING TO LAY PEOPLE OFF- THIS
ALSO HELPED US TO KEEP OUR
RESTAURANT OPEN- BECAUSE WE
OPERATED A FOOD DESERT THERE
NOT A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
THEY'RE NOT A LOT OF RESOURCES
OF PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO GET
MEALS IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES SO A
LOT OF OUR CUSTOMERS COME TO DO
MS. TWO OR HOT CHICKEN. TO GET
THEIR DAILY MEAL I MEAN IT'S-
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
THAT MUCH OF A SPECIAL OCCASION
TYPE OF RESTAURANT. BUT WE
SERVE COMFORT FOOD YOU KNOW
FRIED CHICKEN AND MASHED
POTATOES AND STUFF WARMER AND
STUFF LIKE THAT. SO PEOPLE COME
A LITTLE LITERALLY COME TO US.
TO GET THEIRS THE DAILY MEAL SO
OUR OUR OUR FOOD MODEL OUR
BUSINESS MODEL. IS THAT OF A
CAFETERIA STYLE RESTAURANT-
THEMSELF CALLING THE MEETING TO
MEDIUM THREE. FOURTEEN AT THREE
SITES WHATEVER. IN OUR
CUSTOMERS TYPICALLY COME IN GET
THEIRMEAL WE SERVE LARGE
PORTIONS. AND SO THEY TAKE THAT
HOME. TO THEIR FAMILIES TO FEED
THEIR FAMILIES. AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO SURVIVE. BECAUSE OF OUR
BUSINESS MODEL AND BECAUSE OF
THE GREAT PLAINS PROGRAM. B.
GRADE PLATES PROGRAM WAS VERY
POPULAR HERE IN LOS. THERE
WASN'T A DAY WHEN I WAS OUT
WHEN I WILL BE OUT IN PUBLIC TO
SOMEONE DIDN'T STOP ME ASKME
HOW THEY COULD GET THEIR POWER
CUT HOW WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE.
FOR THEM TO GET THEIR MOTHER OR
THEIR RELATIVES ON THE MEAL
PROGRAM EVERYBODY KNEW ABOUT-
IT'S A- IT'S SATAN THE
RESTAURANTS ALL THE RESTAURANTS
INVOLVED WERE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL. THE TAXI DRIVERS WHO
DELIVER THE MEALS WERE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL. THIS IS A
VERY VERY POSSIBLE PROGRAM IN
IN IN HI YOU KNOW LEGAL-
FORTUNATELY DID TO THANK THE
MAYOR PERSONALLY FOR. PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT SAVES YOU KNOW SO
MANY OF OUR BUSINESS. SANDED
THE TAXI DRIVERS THE TAXI
DRIVERS WERE EXTREMELY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE THE CEILINGS THIS GAVE
THEM WORK. I'M JUST GIVING THEM
MORE. AND SO THE MEAL PROGRAM
IS VERY POPULAR. WAS VERY
POSITIVE OKAY REVENUE FLOWING
INTO OUR POCKETS AND IT
LITERALLY SAVED OUR BUSINESS I
BELIEVE- YOU KNOW I REALLY
LITERALLY SAVED OUR BUSINESS.
AS IT RELATES TO FOOD AND
SECURITY I WAS STILL A BIG
PROBLEM IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
POOR ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES
TO SENIORS. THE GREAT PLACE
PROGRAM HAS ENDED. WELL THE
NEED HAS NOT ENDED AND IN FACT
JUST THIS MORNING AS I WAS
PREPARING FOR TODAY CBS AROUND
STORY ABOUT FOOD SECURITY IN
LOS ANGELES. SPEAKING ABOUT HOW
IT REALLY IMPACTS BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES AND IT TALKED
ABOUT HOW THE SENIORS. SENIOR
CITIZENS ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE. SO I HAVE NOTHING
BUT POSITIVE THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT THE GREAT PLACE PROGRAM.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT WAS WILL
ORGANIZE. IT WAS A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP EVERYBODY GOT ALONG.
THE C. USUALLY LOADED I KNOW
THEY LOVE MY FOOD I GOT
FEEDBACK. AND YOU KNOW I JUST
I'M JUST SORRY WE WERE ALL
SORRY TO SEE THE FUNDING RIGHT
NOW. GRANAHAN AND WE REALLY
WISH NOT ALL ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED RESTAURANTS CAN THE
CAB DRIVERS IN THE SENIORS
WHICH DID IT COULD HAVE BEEN
EXTENDED A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
BUT I WAS VERY PROUD TO BE A
PART OF THE PROGRAM AND BE ABLE
TO GIVE BACK TO THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. HAS SUPPORTED ME OVER
THE YEARS. SAW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS MY
FEELINGS. AND I GIVE YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE AND THANK YOU
MISTER DONUT AND THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE PANELISTS- IT'S WITH
THIS POINT I'D DIE WE WILL OPEN
IT UP TO QUESTIONS. FROM MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR ROB PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER JUST- JUST
COMMENTED. THE GENTLEMAN WHO
JUST SPOKE A GREAT I WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT MENU MADE ME
HUNGRY. THANK YOU MR CHARLES
SHAY IS HE STILL ON THE LINE AS
A- GENERAL AVIATION PILOT ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND A WHOLE
FLOCK OF OTHER PILOTS I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE PROUD
BIRD. AND THEN FINALLY ON A
SERIOUS NOTE TO ALL OF YOU JUST
SPOKE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- RESOURCEFULNESS AND YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE.
DURING THIS RATHER DIFFICULT
TIME THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER THE CENTER
BASED I JUST WANT TO ECHO ON
THE COMMENTS OF THE GOOD A
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE-
ESPECIALLY TO THIS GROUP WHO
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES WHEN THE
PANDEMIC CAT I THINK THE THING
THAT STAND STOOD OUT THE MOST
TO ME DURING THAT TIME WAS THE
OPENING AND THEN THE SHUT DOWN
OF THE RESTAURANTS AND I THINK
MR TOWNSHIP. TOWN HALL SPOKE OF
THAT AS HIS PREACHER DID ALSO
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
RUBBER HITS THE ROAD ON I'M NOT
BELIEVING THAT ANY OF THIS WAS
DONE WITH REAL SCIENCE AND YET
OUR STATE WAS REALLY
CHAMPIONING THE FACT THAT ALL
OF THE REGULATIONS THAT WE'RE
GOING OUT WE'RE BASED ON
SCIENCE AND THAT THERE WAS A
LOT OF TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT SO
I THINK WE NEED TO AGAIN FOCUS
ON THAT GOING FORWARD- IF WE
ARE GOING TO GET THE DATA THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN OF
AND I THINK THAT'S BEEN ALL ON
OUR MINDS ALL OF US. DURING
THIS HEARING IT IS ESSENTIAL IF
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD TRUST BACK
INTO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN THE COMMUNICATIONS-
FROM- THAT SECTOR ODD TO THE
PUBLIC THAT SO WHAT REALLY WAS
LACKING WHEN WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO WEAR A MASK AND THEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO WEAR UNDER A I
GUESS IT WAS WE DIDN'T HAVE TO
WEAR AND THEN WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
WEAR AMID EVERYTHING THAT
FOLLOWED IN THE ON THE ON ON
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IN
PARTICULAR. OF THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY WAS SHUT DOWN BECAUSE
OF SCIENCE AND WE NOW HAVE
LEARNED IN THIS HEARING THAT IT
REALLY WAS MORE ANECDOTAL OR
SPLIT STUFF PROBABLY TOO
SIMPLISTIC BUT IT BASICALLY WAS
MORE TO DO WITH HOW THE VIRUS
WAS ACTING VERSUS HOW WAS
ACTUALLY BEING TRANSMITTED
ESPECIALLY ON AEROSOL OUTDOORS
SO I THINK THIS HAS BEEN GREAT-
TO REALLY HONE IN ON SPECIFICS
I HAVE TO SEE THE GREAT PLATE
SUBPROGRAM WAS. WONDERFUL IN
ORANGE COUNTY ALL ESPECIALLY
FOR ONE OF THE SENIOR SENIOR
MEMBERS IN MY FAMILY WHO IS
BENEFIT WHO BENEFITED FROM. IT
SO THAT YOU HAVE SOME I'VE BEEN
GOING FOR- SENATOR. THE REALLY
GET A START AT TO IT IF. THAT
MIGHT BE CONTINUED ON NATURAL.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THERE. BUT
THANK YOU AGAIN TO ALL OF YOU
AND- I THINK WE'RE ALL
EXTREMELY IMPRESSED WITH YOUR
RESOURCEFULNESS. AND YOU'VE
GIVEN US A LOT OF GUIDEPOST AS
WE GO FORWARD TO TAKE FROM THIS
HEARING. OF SOME THINGS THAT
HAVE TO HAPPEN. AND B. ARE IN
THE BOOKS- WE SAID THERE'S NO
PLAYBOOK WE SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE. THIS YEAR AND NEXT
TO IT TO CREATE THAT PLAYBOOK
SO THAT IT'S THERE FOR. THE
FUTURE GENERATIONS HAVE FILED.
HOPEFULLY WHENEVER EXPERIENCES
AGAIN OR AT LEAST A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS AND LIKE. MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM RIVERSIDE I WON'T
BE HERE EITHER. THERE ARE I
CERTAINLY OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS WILL BE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THEY CAN REFER TO.
SOMETHING WE DIDN'T HAVE AND-
WE HOPE THAT THAT'S WHAT COMES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. AND I
KNOW THE- CHAIRMAN OF SAUCE
CERTAINLY. WANTING THAT SAME
DIRECTION SO WITH THAT THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR PARTICIPATING
WITH US TODAY. AND THANK YOU
VICE CHAIR. BEIJING LET LET LET
ME ADD MY VOICE. TO THE- KIND
OF ADMIRING. THANK IT IS MISMA
UNA. YOU KNOW THE BUSINESS AS-
MARGINS THAT ARE EXTREMELY
TIGHT. AND SO YOU DON'T GET
INTO THIS BUSINESS- JUST FOR
THE MONEY THEY'RE PROBABLY
BETTER USES OF CAPITAL P.
PEOPLE GET IN THIS BUSINESS
BECAUSE- THEY HAVE A LOVE. FOR
THE BUSINESS BUT ALSO HAD A
PASSION FOR SERVING OTHERS. AND
IT AGAIN THOUGH YOU KNOW THE
RESTAURANT. SPACE OCCUPIES
REPLACING ALL OF OUR HEARTS AND
DEFINES IN MANY WAYS OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO WE SHOULD
BE GRATEFUL WE SHOULD ALSO BE A
SUPPORTIVE AS WE CANCEL OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN TO ME. AS
MENTIONED BY HIS PREACHER OR
THE RENT ARREARS SHE'S- THAT SO
MANY YOUR INDUSTRY OR NOT
CARING AS WE MOVE INTO THE
PANDEMICS- WE'VE DONE GOOD WORK
I THINK IN THE LEGISLATURE WITH
RESPECT TO. INDIVIDUALS AND IN
A RESIDENTIAL RANCH- BUT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY GIVEN ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO THIS BURDEN AND I
THINK WE SHOULD NEED SOMETHING
AT ALL- ENDEAVOR TO WORK ON AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THANK YOU
AGAIN TO THOSE PANELISTS- AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PANEL WE'RE GOING TO DEFER TO
FINISH BY. FOUR THIRTY AT THE
LATEST. FOR TODAY'S FINAL PANEL
WE WILL LOOK AHEAD. TO THE POST
ENDEMIC RECOVERY NEEDS OF
RESTAURANTS- WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM DIRECTOR THEIR DEPARTMENT
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL TALK
WITH THE ACTIONS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN BY THE STATE TO SUPPORT
RESTAURANTS. AND OTHER IN
RESTAURANT AND SHE STAY COLD
WHO'S GOT THE CHALLENGES NEEDS
RESTAURANTS THEY MOVE FORWARD.
TOWARD RECOVERY- THE POTENTIAL
LONG TERM ECONOMIC AND BUSINESS
IMPACTS THE BOTANIC AND
RESTAURANTS NEED. A PARTICULAR
EXAMINATION AND THE EFFORTS
RESTAURANTS ARE ENGAGING IN TO
REBUILD CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE OF OUR FIRST PANEL
JOINING US DOCTOR KARANA
DIRECTOR. OF THE PART OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL. HE
HAS. HAD AT AN INITIAL
DEPARTMENT OF HEAVY VERY
CHALLENGING- JOB THROUGHOUT-
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR
MAKING. YOURSELF AVAILABLE
TODAY WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN. BY CHAIR OF THE- YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY. ARE
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
APPROXIMATELYFORTY THOUSAND
ABC LICENSED RESTAURANTS WERE
SUBJECT TO PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER
RESTRICTIONS. IN AN EFFORT TO
REDUCE THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
LIMITING THEIR ABILITY TO FULLY
OPERATE. ARE REALIZING THAT THE
SEGMENT OF THE INDUSTRY WOULD
BE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW IMPORTANT.
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IS TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
OF THE DEPARTMENT IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN TO- DO STAKEHOLDER
OUTREACH TO OFFER ASSISTANCE. I
N. MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE
ISSUED A SERIES OF REGULATORY
RELIEF MEASURES. TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE FLEXIBILITY TO OUR
RESTAURANT LICENSEES. WHICH
WOULD HELP THEM WEATHER OF THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES AHEAD. A
TOTAL OF EIGHTEEN REGULATORY
RELIEF MEASURES WERE PUT INTO
PLACE WHICH INCLUDED- ROUTE-
RELIEF FOR ALCOHOL RETURNS
RETAILER CREDIT. ALSO DELIVERY
AND EXPANDING- LICENSE
PRIVILEGES. COMMUNICATION WAS
WAS A KEY AND A PRIORITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. IN WE MENTALLY
ENGAGED- AND EDUCATIONAL
OUTREACH TO OUR LICENSEES ARE
MAKING SURE THAT THEY WERE
AWARE THAT THE RELIEF AVAILABLE
TO THEM. WE ALSO HAD- UP TO
DATE PAGES ON OUR PUBLIC
WEBSITE THAT DESCRIBED THE
RELIEF AVAILABLE TO EACH
SPECIFIC LICENSE TIED. TWO OF
THE MOST WIDELY USED MEASURES
THAT WERE CREDITED AS A
BUSINESS- SAVING RELIEF I'M
CLUED THE ALLOWANCE FOR OUTDOOR
TRAINING PERMITS. IN THE
ALLOWANCE TO SELL MIXED
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES TO GO. ON
THE OUTDOOR KING PERMITS ALLOW
RESTAURANTS TO TEMPORARILY
EXPAND THEIR LICENSE FROM SAYS
TO ADJACENT AREAS. SUCH AS
PARKING LOTS SIDEWALKS STREETS
INSURE COMMERCIAL SPACE A WEE
BIT SUGAR TOTAL OF TEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED TEMPORARY CATERING
PERMITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
OFFER THESE TYPES OF- PREMISES
EXPANSIONS. I IN ADDITION TO
THE REGULATORY RELIEF MEASURES-
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT AUTHORIZED ABC DO
ALLOW A GRACE PERIOD FOR ANNUAL
RENEWAL FEES ARE THIS PROVIDED
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FOR
RESTAURANTS WERE STRUGGLING TO
PAY THEIR BILLS AND MAKE
PAYROLL. ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
THIRD THIS YEAR- THE GOVERNANCE
AND SIGNED A LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE PROVIDING RELIEF TO
BUSINESSES STRUGGLING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
FROM THE PANDEMIC. ON THIS PLAN
INCLUDED TWO YEAR FEE WAIVERS
TO MORE THAN FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND A. B. C. LICENSEES.
INCLUDING THE AFOREMENTIONED OF
FORTY THOUSAND RESTAURANTS
LICENSED BY A. B. C. THIS
PACKAGE ALSO PROVIDED IMMEDIATE
RELIEF FOR SMALL BUSINESSES- BY
PROVIDING A TWO POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS- GRANTS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. AND THEN ON APRIL
TWENTY NINTH OF THIS YEAR-
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED ASSEMBLY
BILL- EIGHTY- AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE TWENTY SIX
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
SMALL BUSINESS TAX CUTS THAT
CONTINUE- FINANCIAL RELIEF AND
OFFER A CRITICAL LIFELINE TO
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT OWNERS. I MEAN
RECOGNIZES THE VITAL IMPORTANCE
OF RESTAURANTS AND HOW MUCH
RESTAURANTS CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STATE. ABC CONTINUES TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
PROVIDING RELIEF TO ALL OF OUR
LICENSEES AND WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK FOR OTHER MEANINGFUL WAYS
TO SUPPORT THE RESTAURANT AND
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AS IT
RECOVERS FROM THE PANDEMIC. AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND THANK YOU DIRECTOR
ROCKS OUR NEXT PRESENTER TODAY
IS LAURIE THOMAS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BASED GOLDEN GATE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. WHICH IS A
NONPROFIT TRADE ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON HELPING PAY OR
RESTAURANTS SURVIVE AND THRIVE
MISS THOMAS IS ALSO A MEMBER OF
SAN FRANCISCO'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY TASK FORCE. WELCOME IS
THOMAS. BYE THANK YOU EVERYBODY
AND I'D LIKE TO JUST REITERATE.
WHAT SO MANY PEOPLE UPSET
TODAY- I ALSO- HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A RESTAURANT
OWNER MYSELF AND HAVE TWO
RESTAURANTS IN SAN FRANCISCO SO
I HAVE THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. NOT ONLY AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THESE PAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS AT THE GOLDEN GATE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION- BUT
ALSO IT'S TWENTY FIVE YEARS
PLUS- AS A RESTAURANT OWNER A
CCI RESTAURANTS NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS IN SAN FRANCISCO SO
I FEEL THE PAIN. PERSONALLY AS
WELL AS FOR THE REST OF ALL OF
OUR- COLLEAGUES IN THIS
INDUSTRY- AND WHILE WE ARE NOT
A CHAPTER OF THE C. R. A. I
WANT TO THANK MATT SUTTON AND
JOT CONDIE FOR ALL THE WORK
THEY DO IS WE TRY TO HELP.
ELEVATE THEIR VOICES AND OUR
VOICES ARE OUT OF STATE AND-
CERTAINLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME- THAT
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HAS HAPPENED
AND I WANT TO REITERATE IT I
WANTED TO JUST LEAVE. FIVE
THINGS THAT I THINK ARE REALLY
CRITICAL NOW. AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD AND I HESITATE TO SAY
THAT WE'RE IN A POST AT A
RECOVERY STATE BECAUSE I AS THE
REST OF YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL AT
50% CAPACITY. OR LESS INSIDE-
AND SO I DON'T FEEL THAT WERE
OR WERE POST PANDEMIC YET BUT
WE'RE STILL IN THE MIDST OF IT
BUT HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD.
AND HERE ARE I THINK THE FIVE
CRITICAL THINGS THAT WE NEED
GOING FORWARD. NUMBER ONE IS. I
PERSONALLY- I DO NOT KNOW
WHAT'S GOING HAPPEN TO FIFTEEN.
AND I AM CONCERNED BUT PERHAPS-
IT WON'T BE A FULL RETURN TO
NORMALITY AND I'M I'M MAKING A
STRONG CALL OUT I WILL
REITERATE THIS. WITH OUR HEALTH
OFFICER IN SAN FRANCISCO AS
WELL AS CONTRACTS AT THE STATE
LEVEL- THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF
THE STATE COULD ARTICULATE.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH IN REGARDS TO INDOOR
DINING. AND WHAT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED I HAVE A REAL FEAR.
THAT IT MAY BE A RETURN TO
QUOTE A 100% CAPACITY BUT ONLY
IF WE SAY- YOU KNOW COMMIT TO
FULL VACCINATED CUSTOMERS.
BECOME THE POLICE TO CHECK THE
CARDS THAT THAT TYPE OF THING
THAT. PERSONALLY FOR MY TWO
NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANTS
ESPECIALLY RUNNING SHORT
STAFFED WITH NO POSTS- IS GOING
TO BE JUST A NIGHTMARE AND I
CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO IMAGINE
WHAT IT'LL BE FOR FOLKS THAT
HAVE. OUT OF STATE CUSTOMERS AS
MARK THERE. AS MORE OF THEIR
CLIENTELE SO I WOULD REQUEST WE
HAVE THIRTY DAYS- AND I WOULD
REQUEST AT LEAST A WEEK IF NOT
TO WHERE YOU STAY LAURIE IF
THIS IS THE BAD NEWS HERE'S THE
BAD NEWS TELL ALL YOUR MEMBERS.
OR IF THIS IS THE GOOD NEWS
GREAT WE HAVE TIME TO START
HIRING AND- AND MOVING BACK
FORWARD SO I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE. THE MORE INFORMATION
THE SOONER THE POSSIBLE WHETHER
IT'S WHAT WE WANT TO HEAR OR
NOT WE'RE ALL ADULTS AND WE
NEED TO HEAR THAT SO THAT'S
MIGHT LIKE. REALLY STRONG
REQUEST AND WE'VE DONE A GREAT
JOB IN SAN FRANCISCO. THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY TASK FORCE-
THAT WE CONVENED IN APRIL WITH
EIGHTY DIFFERENT. INDUSTRY
FOLKS CITY FOLKS. FAITH LEADERS
ACTIVISTS ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT- FOLKS WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. REALLY
LET US BIND TOGETHER AND FORGE
REAL WORKING RELATIONSHIPS. BUT
LET US COMMUNICATE CLEARLY WHAT
WE NEED AND WORK AS PARTNERS
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE REALLY PROUD
OF IN SAN FRANCISCO GOING
FORWARD AND HAS BEN. SUPER
POSITIVE FOR MYSELF PERSONALLY
AS WELL. THE SECOND THING THAT
I REALLY THINK THAT- WE NEED IN.
ADDITION TO CLARITY AND JUST
REITERATE AND WHAT ERIC AND
EVERYONE ELSE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
SAY DO HERE. THE KIND. OF THE
USE OF THE OUTSIDE SPACES WE
CALL IT THE SHARED SPACES
PROGRAM IN SAN FRANCISCO- THAT-
YOU KNOW FOR SITTING ON
SIDEWALKS CONTINUING THE PARK
WHAT'S CONTINUING MAYBE SOME OF
THE SHARED- STREETS CONTINUING.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK SENATOR DODD AND SENATOR
WINNER OF DONE- WITH- EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE AND EIGHTY
THREE FOURTEEN. AND ALLOWING
AND PUTTING FORTH WE HELP OUT
WHICH PASSES THE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE A. B. C. ON. HOW
TO EXTEND TO MOVE FORWARD THESE
PERMITS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL THAT WORK ERIC IN YOUR
TEAM. AND SENATOR DODD AT AS
WELL. THE THIRD THING THAT I
THINK THAT WE REALLY NEED AND I
THINK YOU GUYS ARE ALL WHERE
THIS AND I'VE BEEN. SITTING ON
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANT
COALITION AS WELL AS WE
DESPERATELY NEED MORE MONEY. IN
TERMS OF RELIEF TO THE
RESTAURANT ORGANIZATION WHAT
MANY OF US ARE CLIMBED OUT OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS OF LOSSES- AND THAT
WHICH THE PPP PROGRAMS WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING. US
EVEN BE ALIVE- IF YOU WANT TO
BE TO AND I AGAIN I THINK THE
STATE FOR ALLOWING US TO DEDUCT
RPP ONE EXPENSES- FOR CERTAIN
FOLKS A QUALIFIED I KNOW NOT
EVERYBODY DID BUT- FOR US. THIS
WAS A BIG A BIG HELP ME
PERSONALLY IT WAS A BIG HELP. I
HAVE SIXTY FIVE EMPLOYEE I HAD
SIXTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OF MY TWO
RESTAURANTS WERE DOWN TO NOW
ABOUT 85% OF THAT- WE HELPED
YOU. TO ADD BACK UP BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER THING SO MORE RELIEF
AND ALSO RELEASED ITS REAL I
PERSONALLY. APPRECIATE BEING
TOLD TWO MONTHS AGO THAT I
QUALIFIED FOR A TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR. CALIFORNIA
RELIEF GRANT AND FOR THE LIFE
OF ME NOBODY CAN TELL ME HOW I
SEE THAT MONEY O HOW I GET
THAT MONEY. SUPER FRUSTRATING
NOT OKAY- AND I KNOW THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING I'M NOT SURE
WHAT'S HAPPENING BUT- THE
RELIEF NEEDS TO BE REAL AND
IT'S- NOT JUST A PR- GROUPS-
BUT IT HAS TO BE REAL. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO
WE NEED MORE R. F. FUNDS IF YOU
ALL CONNECTED IN WASHINGTON.
PLEASE WHATEVER IT TAKES PLEASE
WE SAW A SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS
I BELIEVE IN THE FIRST WEEK IN
TERMS OF APPLICATION NAMED. AN
S. TWENTY EIGHT POINT SIX
BILLION. ARM IN CRIMES ND EVEN
THE MINORITY GROUPS ARE
PROBABLY NOT GONNA ALL GET THE
APPS THAT WERE REQUESTED. THE
NEXT THING AND THIS CAME OUT OF
A DISCUSSION WITH OUR FRIENDS
AT THE R. C. TODAY I THINK THIS
WOULD BE AWESOME. AS IF THERE'S
ANY WAY WE CAN ALL LOBBIED TO
EXTEND THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION
TAX CREDITS. BEYOND THE END OF
THIS YEAR BECAUSE THAT REALLY
HELPS US. TO PAY OUR WORKERS
MORE AND BRING BACK MORE
WORKERS AND IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL PROGRAM. I
KNOW AGAIN THAT SAID THAT THE
STATE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUT
IF ANYTHING WE CAN DO AND IF
THERE'S A SIMILAR PROGRAM AT
THE STATE LEVEL WE COULD CREATE
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME AS WELL.
I LOVED MATH IDEA ABOUT A- A
BONUS STIMULUS THAT PEOPLE COME
BACK TO WORKI THOUGHT THAT WAS
pAWESOME- AND THEN I THINK THE-
BEST THING I WANNA SAY. IS
REALLY REITERATING ON WORKING
TOGETHER AND CLARITY. AND MY
WHOLE JOB THE PAST. FIFTEEN
MONTHS HAS BEEN TRYING TO HELP
EVERYBODY SURVIVE AND TRY TO
INTERPRET. OR AS DR. AND I'D
LIKE TO TALK. HOW TO OPERATE.
ALL OF THE GUIDANCE SO THERE IS
A HUNDRED AND- TWENTY PAGE HELP
ORDER WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN
REALITY I MEAN AND THAT. THINGS
LIKE HEY CAN WE PUT SALT PEPPER
SHAKERS BACK OUT THINGS THAT.
THINGS THAT DOCTORS DON'T DON'T
THINK ABOUT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
RESTAURANT OPERATORS AND- AND
SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE THAT
DIALOGUE AND WE NEED TO BE
ADULTS ABOUT IT WE NEED TO PUSH
BACK AND WE NEED TO SAY THAT'S
A GOOD IDEA BUT THAT'S NOT HOW
IT WORKS IN REALITY. OR YOU
KNOW. EVEN IF YOU DON'T GET RID
OF SIX FOOT DISTANCING- TO
LAURA'S POINT THERE'S NO WAY TO
GET MORE PEOPLE ARE AS YOU.
THINK IT WAS LAURA THEY ARE
JENNIFER'S POINT THERE THERE'S
NO WAY TO GET MORE PEOPLE IN
THE RESTAURANT. SO WORK WITH
WORK WITH INDUSTRY LEADERS WORK
WITH ALL THE RESTAURANT TOURS-
WERE VERY LOGICAL PEOPLE WE
WERE HAPPY TO. HELP AND PUSH
BACK. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY R. FOR FIGHTING TO
HELP SAVE OUR INDUSTRY IT IS SO
CRITICAL ROSES CAFE. IT'S BEEN
THERE FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND BEEN THERE FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS- AND YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A
GIVEN THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SURVIVE JUST BECAUSE WE GO BACK
TO A 100% CAPACITY I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE WHAT LAURA SAID
WE'RE ALL DIGGING OUT. FROM SO
MUCH- FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS WE NONE OF US MADE
MONEY- PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
SETTING THESE LAWS STILL TOOK
SALARIES STILL HAD HEALTH
INSURANCE STILL WERE ABLE TO.
FEED THEIR FAMILIES AND OUR
INDUSTRY WAS NOT. AND SO WE
NEED TO TRY TO HELP STILL
GETTING MONEY BACK INTO OUR
INDUSTRY. AND REALIZE THAT- BUT
THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL THING
TO STILL FOCUS ON IT WE'RE NOT
OUT OF THE WOODS YET YOU ALL
AND IF WE CAN GET MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT JUNE
FIFTEENTH. THAT'LL HELP US FOR
THE WEDDINGS RECEPTIONS AND
EVEN TO JUST KNOW I'M NOT GOING
TO BRING BACK TWO OR THREE MORE
PEOPLE. ARE THEY GONNA SAY WILL
LOWER YOUR GOOD NAME YOU'RE THE
NEW LIKE YOU KNOW I. D. POLICE
AND I'M GONNA SAY THAT DOESN'T
WORK FOR US- WERE NOT THE
WARRIORS WERE NOT JOE LAKE UP
WE DON'T HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO DO THAT AND- YOU
KNOW WE DON'T RUN. GATES WHERE
WE GONNA GO THROUGH AND CHECK
EVERYBODY IS JUST NOT GONNA
WORK SO. IF WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO A FREE RETURN WE JUST
REALLY WANT COMMUNICATION WITH
AS MUCH LEAD TIME AS POSSIBLE
AND- THANK YOU ALL FOR
EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING AND I'M
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO TRY TO HELP
IN ANY WAY- THANK YOU. AND I
THANK YOU SO IT MISSED ALWAYS
SAY AND I DO APPRECIATE. ALL OF
YOUR INPUT BUT ESPECIALLY THE
LAST ONE WAY WITH REGARD TO THE
NEED FOR CLARITY ESPECIALLY AS
WE GET. TO JUNE FIFTEENTH SO.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN OR WHEN I CHEER
AT WHAT IS NOW WE BUY WEEKLY
CALL WITH THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF.
AND THAT WILL BE THE FIRST
QUESTION. ON THIS COMING
MONDAY'S CALL THE ASKED FOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I WORKED
WITH DOCTOR ERAGON SO I'M HAPPY.
TO TALK ANYBODY WANTS MORE.
THANK YOU DO YOU DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND- WE ARE NOW. DOWN TO
THE FINAL. THE AFTERNOON-
MCCALL WHO'S THE FOUNDER BECAME
A MUST. AND ALSO THE HISTORY IS
A PREVIOUS. CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION- AND IT IS A SMALL
WORLD LIFE I'VE BEEN GOING TO
MR CARNEY'S. RESTAURANT HERE
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS. THAT SO
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE BRIDGES I MEAN
OVER THE YEARS. AND THE- PLEASE
WELCOME LOOK FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. AND YOUR MOOD
KEVIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENTIMENT YEAH YES OKAY- LISTEN
I REALLY- APPRECIATE THIS TEAM
OF PEOPLE YOU PUT TOGETHER I'M
HONORED TO BE A PART OF THIS
GROUP OF PEOPLE GREG I'VE I'VE
KNOWN GREG FOR A LONG TIME HE
SAID INCREDIBLY HARD WORKING
PERSON WITH THE HARDEST WORKING
PEOPLE MINISTRY JOHN TALISAY
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE AND- LAURIE
LAURA- AND IT WAS SOMEBODY ELSE
EARLIER I GOT SO YEAH IT'S
IMPRESSIVE I'VE NEVER MET YOU
LADIES BUT IT'S SO IMPRESSIVE-
I'M VERY LUCKY I'VE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS. I OPENED POQUITO MAS BUT
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AND- BY
MYSELF AND THEN WOULD GO INTO-
NINE RESTAURANTS- AND- YOU KNOW
SEVERAL HUNDRED EMPLOYEES BUT I
CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT-
I'M THE GREAT CAME UP WITH A
GREAT COMMENT- LOOK RATHER HE
HE TALKED ABOUT GRATITUDE BEING
GRATEFUL FOR THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO I FEEL GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE
STILL IN BUSINESS I FEEL AND TO
ALWAYS COME OUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG IT'S GONNA LAST. BUT I
AM GRATEFUL THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO TO STAY IN BUSINESS
AND HELP OTHERS I THINK THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IS VERY
INCLUSIVE NO MATTER WHAT WE DO
WE'RE ALL HELPING EACH OTHER
I'M GETTING CALLS FROM
DIFFERENT RESTAURANT OPERATORS
ON A WEEKLY BASIS HELPING THEM
TALK THROUGH TALKING OFF THE
CLIFF LET HIM KNOW THAT IT'S
GOING TO THERE'S SOME HOPE
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT
AND MY COMMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
VERY SHORT I KNOW THAT WE'RE
SHORT ON TIME. BUT YOU KNOW THE
THE REAL THING GOING FORWARD IS
THAT. A COMMUNITY. IS A
CRITICAL. AND I THINK. ONE WHEN
YOU HAVE THE FOUR DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT HAVING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF
COMMUNICATION. IT CREATES
CONFLICT. AND IT CREATES
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE CUSTOMERS
AND THE EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY
ALL FEEL LIKE THEY'VE GOT THE
RIGHT INFORMATION. AND I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS. WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IS WE DON'T WANT OUR
FRONTLINE EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE
TO BE- REGULATORS IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO THAT FOR
PEOPLE WE DON'T WANT OUR
FRONTLINE EMPLOYEES WE DO NOT
TRADE IT IN. AND ALTHOUGH WE
TRAIN HIM SOME PORK NOT
TRAINING CONFLICT RESOLUTION
AND A LOT OF CONFLICT OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THE
COMMUNICATION IS NOT GOOD IT'S
NOT CONSISTENT. AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY RELATIVE TO WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THAT THE COMMUNICATION
COMPONENT OF THIS SORRY FOR THE
HANDS- THE COMMUNICATION
COMPONENT IS DEALT WITH AND IF
WE DO WE ARE CLEAR FOR OUR UP
FRONT WE DO GIVE LEAD TIME. WE
GET PROCESSING TIMES TO PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT JUST SLAM SOMETHING
ON PEOPLE IT CREATES PROBLEMS
AND YOU SEE A LOT OF CONFLICT
OUT THERE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
PEOPLE AREN'T GETTING. ENOUGH
TIME TO PROCESS- INDUSTRY WISE.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE A LOT OF
RESTAURANTS HOBBY START CLOSING
BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE CLOSE IN
A COUPLE DAYS A WEEK. MAYBE
EVEN MORE THAN THAT THEY COULD
BECAUSE OF THE SHORTAGE OF.
FOOD AND A SHORTAGE OF PEOPLE
BYE I THINK THE DEEP LABOR
ISSUE IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
ISSUE FOR A LOT OF RESTAURANTS
RIGHT NOW WE'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE WE WE'VE HELD ON TO
OUR TEAM. I HAD TO CLOSE THE
THAT WHEN A PARK RESTAURANT
TEMPORARILY BECAUSE THIS NEXT
IN ASKARI FARMAN. I WILL OPEN
THAT UP AGAIN THIS SUMMER
OTHERWISE WE HAVEN'T LOST
ANYBODY. THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART IS IT THERE'S A LADY NAMED
PATTY REVELA SHE'S BEEN MY
PARTNER OW- FOR MANY YEARS
AND- SHE HAS BEEN OUT RUNNING
THE COMPANY. FOR THE LAST
FOURTEEN MONTHS. I HAVE BEEN
OUT BECAUSE OF MY AGE I COULD
LEAVE MY HOUSE. SO WE MET ON MY
FRONT PORCH- THREE TO FIVE
TIMES A WEEK TWELVE FEET APART
AND SHE WOULD GO OUT AND RUN
THE COMPANY. I THINK THERE'S SO
MANY PATTIES OUT THERE THERE'S
SO MANY STORIES ABOUT GREAT.
EMPLOYEES WHO AND GREAT IN THIS
CASE PARTNER WHO HAVE. REALLY
CARRIED THE RESTAURANT STRIP SO
MANY AND WE HAVE TO START
THINKING ABOUT THOSE. BUT I
THINK THAT. THE NUMBER ONE
THING IS NOT ONLY DO WE NEED
MORE MONEY AND IF THERE'S A
SIXTY BILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
AND ONLY TWENTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. FIND THE OTHER THIRTY
TWO. OKAY THERE'S JUST THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON NOT TO
FIND IT. OKAY IT'S OBVIOUS THAT
EXIST FIND IT FIND IT WOULDN'T
GIVE THAT. THE OTHER THING IS.
THIS IS A TWO TO THREE YEAR
RECOVERY. A LOT OF US HAVE
EVER. WE ARE WE ARE IN THIS
BUSINESS WE BELIEVE IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE LOVE WHAT WE'RE
DOING. AND IT'S NOT FOR THE
MONEY. YOU KNOW IF IT WAS FOR
THE MONEY WE DO SOMETHING ELSE.
BUT IF WE DO LIST BECAUSE WE
LOVE SERVING WE LOVE SERVING
FOOD AND THE ONE THING THAT YOU
CANNOT DO. IS TAKEN INTO ST
HOSPITALITY- AT AND JUST LET IT
GET A RACIST BECAUSE IT IS
PANDEMIC MORE IMPORTANTLY. YOU
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT. GREAT
PEOPLE IN THIS INDUSTRY THAT
REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN. HEARD YET
SO I'M GLAD YOU'RE DOING THIS.
WE NEED TO HEAR MORON. AND I
CAN YOU FEEL SO. THAT TOP NOT
UNDERSTAND IT THIS IS THE THREE
TWO TO THREE YEAR RECOVERY
PLAN. IS CRITICAL BECAUSE IT IS
THAT KIND OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO HELP SUPPORT THE
SMALL RESTAURANTS. THE PPP WAS
FINE BUT IT WASN'T ENOUGH EVEN
BOOK THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH AND I
SAID TO NOT IMMEDIATELY PUT OUT
THAT YES WE'RE GONNA FIND
ENOUGH MONEY FOR THIS OTHER
PROGRAM WE'RE GOING TO GET WHAT
YOU NEED. BECAUSE WE ALL SIT
HERE WITH UNCERTAINTY AND
UNCERTAINTY IS WHEN WE START
MAKING BAD DECISIONS WHEN WE
START MAKING OKAY LATE PEOPLE
LOTS OF GOING TO CLOSE THIS
RESTAURANT I GOTTA CUT
SOMETHING OFF. IT'S IS THAT
UNCERTAINTY THAT IS CREATING A
GREAT MANY PROBLEMS THAT NEED
TO BE CLARIFIED. AND
EVERYBODY'S POINT OF THIS WHOLE
MEETING IS COMMUNICATION. IS
THE KEY AND IT NEEDS TO BE GOOD
AND IT NEEDS TO BE UP FRONT AND
WE NEED TO HAVE PROCESSING TIME
SO WE CAN DEAL WITH THINGS WE
ARE. AN INDUSTRY THAT CAN PIVOT
TO ANYTHING BUT- WE NEED HELP
AND WE HELP IN COMMUNICATION
AND WE OBVIOUSLY NEED HELP WITH
THE MONEY AS WELL GREG I JUST
I'M GOING TO SEE MA'AM IT NOW I
CAN LEAVE MY HOUSE. LAST WEEK
THE FIRST TIME I CLEAN MY HOUSE
IN. FOURTEEN MONTHS I'LL COME
TO SEE. THANK YOU RESTRICT- I
I'M- PLEASE TO HEAR THAT THE
PLANT LOCATION. WILL BE RE
OPENING CIRCLES THAT SOMEONE
CLOSE TO ME SO. THANK YOU.
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE- I AM
GOING TO QUICKLY. ASK FOR THE
PUBLIC. IF THERE'S ANY COMMENT-
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR FINAL THOUGHTS.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON ANYONE
WISHING BRIDE COULD PUBLIC
COMMENT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND COVERED
RELATED CLEANING PROTOCOLS WE
SENTENCE SENTENCE TO TIME
LIMITS AND TEST MYSELF ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH
PROVIDER ASKED TO LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS. TO BROADLY ONE
MINUTE- FOR PUBLIC COMING LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES. HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE AT
SEEING NONE- THE OVERFLOW ROOM
FOR HERE IS ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
LET'S GO TO TWENTY FOUR ISSUES
IN A COMMENT. SEEING NONE- AND
LET ME KNOW MR MODERATOR-
ORGANISED MODERATION SAY- IF
YOU COULD CHECK THE
TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE FOR
ANYBODY WISHING TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
END SO LET'S LET'S CHECK ONE
MORE TIME MR MODERATOR. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE
THEN ZERO PLEASE. AND WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. I THANK YOU
IN WITH THAT AND LET ME LET ME
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
LET ALONE- FOR YOUR THOUGHTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
SHARE NEW MEN I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE- COMMENTS
THAT BEEN SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SHARED WITH US THE FEEDBACK.
ONE OF MY GOALS IN IN
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING
WAS TO REALLY UNDERSTAND. NOT
JUST THE ELEMENTS THAT WE COULD
CHANGE IT SHOULD THERE BE
ANOTHER PANDEMIC IN OUR
LIFETIME- BUT ALSO TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
AND I ASKED A QUESTION AT THE
VERY FIRST PART OF THE HEARING
WHICH WAS. WHAT DO YOU. THINK
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE ONE TIME
INCENTIVES LOOK LIKE AND I
THINK. OVERALL THROUGH OUR
PANELS I UNDERSTAND THAT YET
YOU KNOW EXTENSION TO EXISTING
OR NEW TAX CREDIT IS EXQUISITE
ARE IMPORTANT- INCENTIVE TO
WORK PROGRAMS. TO DEAL WITH THE
LABOR. SHORTAGE ISSUES THAT ARE
VERY REAL- AND IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE NOT JUST SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA BUT TO THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY IS. AS I LEARNED IN IN
THIS AT. A SESSION AND PANEL
AND ALSO- YOU KNOW DID THAT
THAT WE HAVE TO BE MORE CLEAR
AS A STATE- ABOUT. THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE AND THEY HAVE TO
BE TRULY ACCESSIBLE AND NOT
JUST IN THEORY BUT IN PRACTICE.
AND SO- THOSE ARE SOME OF MY
BIG TAKE AWAYS I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING I
THINK THERE WERE MANY. TIMES
AND IN THESE ON THESE PANELS
THAT I HEARD A TRUE SINCERITY
IN FRUSTRATION- ON THAT
BECAUSE- IT'S BEEN VERY HARD-
AND WE'VE WANTED TO DO RIGHT.
BY YOU KNOW THE BUSINESS TEAM
FORTY EMPLOYEES. AND SO
CERTAINLY I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT IN NO WAY HAVE ANY OF
THE ACTIONS THAT THE STATE
TAKEN. DO I BELIEVE I HAD THE
INTENTION. OF YOU KNOW YOU
CREATE SUCH. BUT THE REALITY
ARE IS THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED A LOT OF HARDSHIPS AND
THOSE HARDSHIPS HAVE BEEN
MANIFESTED. IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS SO I WANT TO
SYNC THE- EVERYONE FOR THEIR
VERY CANDID. CLEAR AND DIRECT
REMARKS AND HAVE BEEN MADE AND-
I CERTAINLY HAVE A TASK AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU SHARE IN TERMS OF HOW WE
CAN ENSURE THAT WE DO BETTER
FOR THE INDUSTRY. AND WE HELP
AN INDUSTRY THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT- AND FOR SOME
ECONOMIES LIKE MINE THAT RELY A
LOT ON TREES AND- THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT. ITS CORE TO
THAT TOURISM THAT BRINGS FOLKS
TO THE CENTRAL COAST SO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS AND OUR TIME AND
PARTICIPATION. AND THANK THANK
YOU CEREMONY- LET LET ME LET ME
ECHO- YOU'RE VERY ELOQUENT
COMMENTS SO TO THE PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY. WE THANK YOU FOR MAKING
SALES AVAILABLE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
YOUR DILIGENCE- AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONSIDER
DIFFERENT APPROACHES. TO THE
INDUSTRY PARTICIPANTS TO
PROTEST A WEEK YOU KNOW WE
THANK YOU- AND WE EMPATHIZE-
AND WE OR DIE TRULY ROOTING FOR
YOU AND COMMITTED TO DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
YOU. IN YOUR RECOVERY THE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS. AFTER A DESTRUCTION AS
SUBSTANTIAL IT'S COVERED YOUR
INDUSTRY. WILL NOT RETURN TO
THE WAY THINGS. WERE. AND WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO TEST FIRE WOULD
LIKE YOUR THOUGHTS CONSIDERED
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT S. C. P. OR AT
S. P. N. DOT CA DOT GOV WE LOOK
FORWARD TO INCLUDING YOUR
WRITTEN COMMENTS SUGGESTIONS IN
THE OFFICIAL. HEARING RECORD
AND OUR DEEPEST THANKS AGAIN TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED THE
END OF THE STAFF THAT MADE THIS
POSSIBLE- I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION- AS
WE CONSIDERED THE BEST WAYS TO
NOT ONL PREPARE. FOR THE
RECOVERY BUT TO ENSURE THAT WE
AS SKILLFULLY AS ARE NEVER
CAUGHT AS UNPREPARED AGAIN- FOR
A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY SUCH
AS THIS SO WE'VE NOW COMPLETED
TODAY'S AGENDA. AND WITH THAT
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC MERCY RESPONSE IS A
GIANT THANK YOU ALL.